Ja, und aus dem Weltall sind wir zu euch gekommen, um euch zu sagen, you're doomed. Ich klinge heute so ein bisschen wie so eine Mischung aus Schalz, Aas, Nauvour und Mickey Mouse auf Drogen. Keine Ahnung, irgendwie die Party gestern war einfach mal echt sehr störerisch. Bin froh, dass wir unseren Termin um zwei Stunden verlegt hätten, weil ich hätte sonst verschlafen. Aber war eine gute Party. Deutlich, ja. Kann man echt nicht anders sagen.
Tim ist mein Vater, na.
Hat sich gelohnt. Ja, jetzt haben wir schon zwei Darth Vader hier in der Sendung. Der eine atmet und der andere geht jetzt nicht.
Ich bin Luke, jetzt bleib ich noch näher.
Mit diesem Kopfhörer sehen wir sowieso alle aus wie Prinzessin Leia. Nur, dass sie dieses Mikrofon nicht hatte.
Hast du letztens gesehen, da hat einer ein Bild gepostet, wo Prinzessin Leia mit ihrem Double sich auf so einer Art Sonnenbank liegt.
Mit ihrem Double, du meinst jetzt ein Originalfoto von dem Set oder was?
Ja, zwei Mal Leia nebeneinander und sie liegen so in der Sonne.
Das ist aber schon ein Altersport, aber bei Nuttcore ist das unter anderem jetzt zu klein.
Aber wieso hat sie einen Double?
Die drehen das doch nicht selbst, da würde doch die Versicherung austicken.
Außerdem war die doch spätestens im dritten Teil, da mussten sie immer in ihren Szenen an die Wand lehnen, weil die so starke Alkoholprobleme hatte, dass wohl kaum eine Szene zu schmalen über sich gebracht hat.
Das glaube ich ja nicht. Niemals, nein. Nicht Prinzessin Leia.
Seine Jugendliebe.
Aber mit diesem Bild, mit diesem Double, da kriegt das Wort Double Penetration gleich eine ganz andere Bedeutung.
Oh, jetzt sind wir nicht mehr jugendfrei, oder was?
Oh Shit, stimmt, wir machen ja unsere Sendung alle nicht.
Genau, wir machen ja hier eine Kindersendung, die heißt Mobile Max und wir sind in Ausgabe Nr. 37.
Echt, 37?
Ja, wenn ich jetzt schon so eine Ansagerstimme habe, muss ich das natürlich auch gleich nutzen. Und ja, wir werden wieder mal versuchen, hier über die karge Nachrichtenlage rüber zu bürsten. Ich habe ja auch zwei Joker-Themen in der Tasche. Zwei Joker-Themen, das ist gut. Ihr könnt euch freuen auf zwei Joker-Themen in Kollaboration mit hilfreichen Kräften in unserem tollen Chat, von dem ich nicht genau weiß, ob er diese Live-Sendung hier durchgehend verfolgen kann, weil unser Internet-Ablink gerade extrem wackelig ist.
Ausnahmsweise mal.
Es läuft da ein kleiner Bot, wo die Leute irgendwie live versuchen, mitzubekommen, wenn wir denn mal über was anderes zu reden. Und dann haben sie die Möglichkeit, diesem Bot zu sagen, dass da neue Kapitelmarken an sind. Und ich hab das letzte Mal ja schon mal probiert. Es kam dann noch tatsächlich was Brauchbares bei raus. Das mit der Positionierung und wann wo, das war noch alles so ein bisschen, naja, schwierig. So, also da wirklich genau aus dem Chat-Log heraus, Zeiten zu bekommen, wo dann wirklich was angefangen hat. Aber man kann schon mal sagen, überhaupt die Sendung thematisch zu gliedern. Da hat es schon so beigetragen. Und ich hab mir dann einfach mal die Mühe gemacht, das dann eben auch so weit anzupassen, dass die Kapitel-Anfänge so halbwegs stimmen. Das ist eigentlich zu viel Arbeit. Also das ist eigentlich genau das, was ich eben nicht will oder weswegen man diese ganze Kapitel-Geschichte normalerweise nicht macht. Aber wenn es halt irgendwie gelingt, das so zu automatisieren, auf welchem Wege auch immer, dass man eben auch weiß, hm hm hm, ja. Ich meine, klar, wenn wir jetzt hier etwas strukturierter, als wir das normalerweise machen, hier rangehen und sagen, und jetzt reden wir über dieses Thema, ja, dann kann ich hier irgendwie auch auf eine Taste drücken und so. Und ich vermute auch, darauf wird es hinauslaufen müssen. Aber man kann das ja auch mal ausprobieren, ob das nicht auch irgendwie mit dieser ganzen Crowdsourcing-Dynamik auch in irgendeiner Form machbar ist. Naja, auf jeden Fall, das Endeergebnis war diese Chapter-Datei. Ich hab die dann erstmal noch nicht defaultmäßig in den Feed gemacht. Sollte jetzt wieder brauchbare Kapitelmarken rauskommen, dann werde ich diesmal die in den Feed werfen und die MP3-Datei separat linken. Und dann muss ich irgendwie mal gucken, wie ich verhindern kann, wie dieses blöde WordPress dann nicht automatisch beide Dateien in den Feed packt. Das ist wirklich so ein Dreck, dieses WordPress.
Eigentlich ist das eine schöne Idee, du verlinkst ein Datei.
Ja, aber das muss man doch, ja, aber er kann doch nicht einfach irgendwie eine Enclosure erzeugen, ohne dass man das weiß. Ich meine, das ist ein vollkommen intransparenter Vorgang. Wo ist da irgendwie der Pop-Up, der fragt, ich habe einen Link gefunden, möchtest du automatisch eine Enclosure anlegen lassen? Ich meine, er könnte einen doch zumindest fragen. Nein, er macht es einfach. Obwohl man sowieso schon eine Enclosure hat, dann ist immer wieder nicht klar, wenn zwei Enclosures drinstehen in einem Erst-Ers-Eintrag, welcher denn jetzt genommen wird, der erste oder der zweite?
Wenn zwei Enclosures sich streiten, freut sich die dritte.
Wir sind live, wir sind in Farbe, wir nehmen auf. Ich habe irgendwie Start eingegeben in den Chat. Insofern ist alles super. Ich habe wieder ein anderes Audio-Setup als beim letzten Mal. Und ich werde das nächste Mal schon wieder ein anderes Audio-Setup haben. Da mache ich jetzt aber im Einzelnen nicht so drauf eingehen. Nur hier befindet sich alles permanent im Fluss. Und es ist ein einziges Experiment. So, und jetzt können wir ja mal zum Thema kommen. Kapitelmarkengelegenheit. Na, zu welchem Thema wollen wir denn kommen?
Jetzt wo Apple gesagt hat, dass dieses Jahr keine Produkte mehr announced werden, haben wir eigentlich auch schon Weihnachtsferien gegeben.
Das stimmt, aber wir können jetzt einfach anfangen, einen nach dem anderen davon zu kaufen und auszuprobieren und zu besprechen. So, und heute, in der heutigen Ausgabe geht es um die Magic Mouse.
Du hast jetzt Glück gehabt, wir müssen, ich muss mir jetzt einen dämlichen 27 Zoll iMac kaufen, den ich nicht brauche.
Genau, ich bin billig bei weggekommen.
Weil ihr ein anderes Produkt.
Ach so, ich kaufe den 27 Zoll.
Ich kaufe mir die Remote.
Okay, ich kaufe mir das No Leopard.
Die Mode ist billiger.
Du hast noch nicht Snow Leopard raus.
Ich habe hier schon Snow Leopard gekauft.
Wissen wir, gestern war er bei der Firma, wo ich Arbeit in der Apple angestellte, weil die bei unserer Partnerfirma irgendwie bei uns sich das iPhone-App angeguckt hat. Und dann meinte mein Chef, die würde ja auch mal zu mir kommen und sich auch mal irgendwie das Techstar-iPhone-App angucken. Da kam ich vielleicht ins Schwitz, nicht, dass sie noch verwandt ist mit Steve, und irgendwie muss ich das mal im Bildschirm aufräumen, geguckt, ob irgendwie alles okay ist, mal jetzt das Horn zur Seite schieben und so. Dann kommt man ganz schön ins Schwitz mit so einem Apple-Mitarbeiter.
Was für eine Art Mitarbeiter war denn das? Ich meine, du musst jetzt nicht so sehr ins Detail gehen, aber es gibt ja in Deutschland eigentlich keine besonders hochrangigen.
Das war eine Frau, die wohl bei dieser Partnerfirma, was Soundcloud ist, ist ja auch nichts, kein Geheimnis, und die entwickelte auch eine iPhone-App für Soundcloud. Soundcloud ist wie Flickr für Bilder, ist das gleiche für Audio, und die haben jedenfalls auch eine iPhone-App, und die sollte sich das da wohl angucken oder bequatschen, ich weiß nicht genau. Es ist mir auch nicht klar, warum Apple-Mitarbeiter rumreisen und sich iPhone-Apps angucken.
Vielleicht überlegen sie sich, ob sie was featuren, dass sie in den nächsten Werbespot kommen, der ist ein App-Verwert.
Kann sein, jedenfalls kamen sie auch mal zu mir, hat sich alles vorführen lassen, aber das iPhone-App fand sie nicht so spannend. Hat sie nur zwei Minuten geguckt oder so und sich ein bisschen zeigen lassen. An dem Reader, also an dem Texte-Reader, da hat sie sich bestimmt eine halbe Stunde zeigen lassen. Den fand sie ja spannend. iPhone-Apps sieht es wahrscheinlich so viele und jeden Tag, das reißt sie nicht mehr vom Hocker. Aber der Reader dazu?
War das eine deutsche?
Nein, nein, Englisch. USA oder Englisch, könnte sogar USA sein, bin mir nicht sicher.
Also eine richtige Apple-Mitarbeiterin sozusagen?
Also nicht die Apple-Deutschland-Itunes-Store.
Jetzt verstehe ich ja, warum du so schwitze hast, weil du irgendwie Angst hast, dass du gleich gestieft wirst.
Stell dir vor, die ist verwandt mit dem oder so.
Verwandt?
Die Tochter von Steve Jobs?
Ach, Steve Jobs ist doch so ein weisen Kind, der ist mit gar keinem verwandt.
Aber heute war jedenfalls, hab ich da erst mal so...
Aber am Ende war dann doch alles super.
Am Ende war doch alles super. Das ist doch sehr schön.
Da ist einmal mein App abgestürzt und so. Da meinte sie, das ist ja kein Problem, sie weiß ja, ist ja im Simulator gewesen, ist ja in development, Hauptsache, es wird nicht gechipt.
Kommt eh nicht durch in der Review.
Ja, aber...
Da kam ja gestern noch ein lustiges kleines Thema. Mit diesem Mein Kampf, der in Spanien im App-Store veröffentlicht ist.
Mein Kampf.
Mein Kampf. Hitler ist mein Kampf mit einem schönen kleinen Hakenkreuz als Eigen. Ab neun Jahren.
Was, als Buch oder als Audiobuch?
Nein, als App-Store, als Buch quasi, als E-Book. Kostellosen Unterlagen.
Nicht kostenlos.
Auf Spanisch?
Ja, auf Spanisch. Also nach Spanisch reicht das, glaube ich, auch absolut legal. Ich finde es allerdings bizarr, dass es wirklich überhaupt kein Problem ist, offensichtlich im amerikanischen App-Store, meinen Kampf mit Hakenkreuz und einem Pipapoo ab neun Jahren durchzudrücken. Aber jeder Twitter-Client und jeder Chat-Client ab 17 plus ist, weil man ja theoretisch möglicherweise da Brüste sehen könnte.
Oder im Internet meinen Kopf runterladen könnte.
Aber meinen Kampf, sagt man ja, ist auch intellektuell jetzt eher so auf dem Niveau von Kleinkindlich.
Ja, also ich hab jetzt...
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass er da jetzt wirklich ein Meisterwerk geschaffen hätte.
Ich bin ja auch nicht der Meinung, gefährlich das wäre, sondern es ist eigentlich einer der vier Punkte, wo er kein Meisterwerk geschaffen hat. Also ich bin ja nicht der Meinung, dass man meinen Kampf verbieten sollte oder so. Das ist ja nicht mal verboten. Also erstmal ist es natürlich ganz offensichtlich ein Urheberrechtsverstoß, meinen Kampf jetzt zu veröffentlichen. Weil ihr wisst, über welche Stiene meinen Kampf verboten ist. Aber das läuft jetzt aus, das Urheberrecht.
Es gibt so Stimmen, dass die schwarz-gelbe Regierung jetzt Urheberrechtsansprüche noch verlängern will, damit es die Bayern nicht meinen Kampf noch nicht mehr hingeben müssen.
Aber es ist 70 Jahre nach dem Tod des Autors, was irgendwie nach 45 ist, also...
2010.
Ist der 40 gestorben?
Der ist 45 gestorben.
Also 2015. 70 Jahre nach dem Tod des Autors oder wenn es eine Übersetzung ist, dann nach dem Tod des Übersetzers.
Na vielleicht behaupten sie einfach, sie hätten es nachträglich dann nochmal übersetzt in lesbares Deutsch, weil es vorher alles in verherrerdeutsch war.
Dann mach dir nichts, dann bringst du die Version, die nicht übersetzt wurde, raus von vorher.
Na gut, wie auch immer, wer Lust hat, meinen Kampf mal in seiner vollen Bandbreite zu erleben, ist der in Deutsch oder in Spanisch?
In Spanisch.
Ah so, in Spanisch.
Kennt ihr, kann man auch eins einfach kaufen, ich glaube, gibt es sogar im iTunes-Store, ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht genau.
Der Türke, der irgendwie aus dem Kampf rief.
Genau, der heißt Serdar Somuncu, spricht man das so aus und seh, auf Türkisch. Sehr lustig und der liest halt meinen Kampf vor, so auf der Bühne. Da darf man das dann, weil das ist dann sozusagen künstlerische Interpretation. Und das ist es wirklich. Und es ist einfach original, die Texte, und du legst dich einfach weg, was da für ein Höhensinn drinsteht, warum dieses Buch wirklich verboten wird.
Das ist wirklich so sinnlos.
Das müsste man eigentlich an alle ausgeben und hier liest mal.
Das Buch ist ja auch nicht verboten.
Sondern?
Du darfst es nur nicht drucken, weil in Bayern halt die Copyright-Dings gehört. Wenn du es aber hast zum Beispiel oder aus dem Ausland dir besorgst und so, dann ist alles gar kein Problem.
Super, jetzt haben wir auch mal Hitler-Content hier gehabt bei Mobile Max.
Das gleich zum Anfang.
Ja, das gleich zum Start weg, sodass erst mal hier alles klar ist. Die Messlatte ist hochgelegt. Und ja, können wir vielleicht noch mal eine kleine Teamrundenvorstellung machen?
Ich bin der Dennis.
Du bist der Dennis. Wie immer, wenn der Dennis bist du?
Ich bin Huckel.
Und Huckel ist auch wieder da. Was?
Ist Huckel eigentlich so audio-technisch?
Ich bin ja links. Naja, so wie wir jetzt hier so sitzen irgendwie. Also ich bin sozusagen der Hörer.
Achso, und ihr teilt euch die Mitte?
Also Huckel ist jetzt akustisch. Also man muss jetzt sagen, wir hören jetzt sozusagen diese Links-Rechts-Verteilung im Kopfhörer nicht.
Das ist doch Dolby Surround. Und ich bin die Centerbox. Ihr seid die Rear-Left und Rear-Right.
Ja, Dennis ist links und Huckel ist... und ich bin so ein bisschen weniger links und Huckel ist ein bisschen rechts und Max ist ein bisschen mehr rechts.
Ich bin total links.
Genau. Max, du bist sozusagen der Rechtsradikale hier.
Der erste Jung, wie heißt der jetzt?
Gutenberg.
Der zurückgetretene Altnazi.
Was? Der Rechtsanwalt.
Der Rieger, genau.
Der Verstorbene meinst du.
Ich hab jetzt mal meinen Alters-Store nach Hitler gesucht und da findet man Hitler eine Bilanz an der Fernsehsee und Leute, die Hitler eine Bilanz kauften, kauften auch der Bulle von Tölz. Und die Cosby-Show.
Die hatt ich schon lange im Verdacht.
So, jetzt waren wir ja gerade bei iPhone S. Sollen wir nicht da gleich noch bleiben, weil da hätten wir ja noch eine kleine Baustelle, oder? Max will, glaub ich.
Was denn?
Ich hab gejailbragt, ich hab gejailbragt.
Nein, das mein ich gar nicht. Aus, aus.
Na hier mit dem...
.Schnitt mit der Bild-App. Weil es ist ja auch mit dem Nazi-Vergleich jetzt nicht so weit weg.
Oh man, ey. Diese Sendung gerät vollständig aus den Fugen. Und das noch in der alten 20 Minuten.
Bild-App?
Ach so.
Ja, ja, ja. Ach stimmt, das haben wir alle schön lustig mitbekommen. Das ja Springer hat ja beschlossen, auf dem iPhone nicht mehr stattzufinden in Zukunft. Wie ihr vielleicht alle gehört habt.
Weil mit dieser... Was hat er gesagt? Das hier, dieses... Alles ist umsonst im Internet. Diese Einstellung, das würde irgendwie gar nicht gehen, diese Mentalität. Diese Umsonstmentalität aus dem Internet.
Die haben jetzt echt zum Kampf geblasen, die Penner.
Zum so seinem Kampf.
Was für ein Übergang. Mein Überlebenskampf.
Jetzt müssen wir aber erst mal... Ja, wir springen jetzt hier mal in diese Schlucht rein und wir sind uns sicher, dass uns bis auf dem Weg nach unten schon noch irgendwas einfallen wird, wie wir Samt aufladen.
Der Gedanke auf jeden Fall ist, sie haben jetzt ein iPhone-App und das...
Sie werden eins haben oder sie haben schon eins?
Ich glaube, sie haben schon welche.
Das ist in der Mache, ich hab da Collections.
Und du hast Connections zu Springer, oh mein Gott. Und daraufhin soll... Und darüber kann man Inhalte kaufen, soweit so ihr absolutes Recht, aber eben um...
Es gibt das Programm erst mal für 1,60 Euro, was irgendwie den Bild-Content bis zum Ende des Jahres irgendwie auf dein iPhone bringt. So habe ich es verstanden.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Also bis zum Ende des Jahres. Aber weil natürlich niemand so einen Scheiß kaufen würde, sperren sie einfach den Zugang vom iPhone zu ihrer Seite, indem sie irgendwie den User-Agent abfragen und dann sagen, du kriegst nichts. Wobei alle anderen Smartphones weiterhin diesen Schrott kriegen.
Android wird als nächstes abgesperrt, weil für Android ist dann das nächste App fertig.
Ja, und wenn...
Ich glaube, für Windows-Mobile ist es da, die Windows-Mobile-Loser werden bis in alle Ewigkeiten Bild-Springer-Content weiterhin kostenlos genießen dürfen. Nehme ich mal an, weil wahrscheinlich lohnt es sich dafür nicht.
Aber die machen doch auch hier Wolfram Alpha, jetzt wo sie ihre 50 Dollar ab draußen haben, haben sie auch spontan ihre Webseite nicht mehr iPhone-optimeist. Ach, nicht? Also als ich da letztens drauf raus bin, sah das wieder aus, so wie ganz früher, also unoptimiert.
Ist ihnen versehentlich kaputt gegangen?
Das ist eine Sauerei. Naja, ich meine, sie kriegen irgendwie ihr Geschäftsmodell nicht gebacken und dann kommen sie irgendwie so, nicht dass mir jetzt Bild.de-Content oder was auch immer irgendwie interessieren würde, aber die Art und Weise bestätigt doch, dass ich mich weiterhin nicht dafür interessieren muss.
Werden doch eh gegen die Wand laufen damit.
Das sowieso. Vor allem, sie wissen auch noch nicht so richtig den Preis, aber sie wollen jetzt mit diesem Versuchsmodell bis Ende des Jahres gucken, wie viele Leute das klicken, kaufen, machen und tun und sich die Seite angucken und dann fürs nächste Jahr irgendwie dann so mit, wahrscheinlich In-App-Purchase, dass du dir irgendwie pro Woche, pro Monat, pro Jahr wie auch immer dann irgendwie den Bild-Content da für dein iPhone freischalten kannst und du kannst es dann auch nur in diesem App dann irgendwie dir angucken oder wie. Das heißt, du kannst dir im Safari irgendwie klicken oder im Twitter mal irgendwie einen Bild-Link lesen, sondern nee, du musst dann immer irgendwie deine Links in dieses App reinkriegen. Das ist doch total bekloppt.
Na, obwohl das könnten sie ja, ich meine, das könnten sie ja über ein Redirect hinkriegen. Ich glaube allerdings nicht, dass sie da Prioritäten drauf festlegen. Also sie könnten ja so machen, dass ein Safari dann im Redirect auf das App kommt.
Ich glaube, die werden bis Ende des Jahres gemerkt haben, dass es alles gar nicht geht und dann ist auch wieder vorbei mit dem Spuk. Aber ich meine, die... Die Geschichte an sich ist doch schon... Ja, wie hast du schon gesagt, die sind im freien Fall und sie versuchen irgendwie Rettungsstürme zu ziehen und die gehen auf und platzen aber sofort, weil es viel zu schwer ist, weil es geht nach unten und zwar richtig schnell.
Ja, und vor allem ist es, was sie irgendwie selber nicht verstehen, ist, die denken ja wirklich, sie hätten irgendwie original Content, der die Leute interessieren würde. Das ist ja nicht so. Das ist einfach die Zeitung.
Die Bild hat durchaus Fußball-Content, der ganz spannend ist, glaube ich.
Das muss er schon sagen.
Das ist einfach werbeförderndes Geschreibsel und kein Content. Die Zeitung ist doch irgendwie so ein Surfboard für Werbungskonsum. Und wenn sie das zu teuer bereitstellen, und ich denke, dass dieser Weg im Netz sozusagen zu teuer ist, so mit irgendwie abrunterladen und tralala, wollen sie denn da regelmäßig was nehmen? Oder ist das nur, du kaufst einmal die App und dann hast du die?
Sie wollen regelmäßig was machen.
Später dann. Aber jetzt ist das erst mal nur eine App, was bis Ende des Jahres dich bei bild.de oder irgendwie so surfen lässt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert. Also nicht mit Bild.
Warum nicht mit Bild?
Das ist eine der meistgelesenen Zeitungen überhaupt.
Ja, aber nur weil sie irgendwie billig ist, beziehungsweise im Netz halt so kommen.
Und vor allem schneidet sich die User-Group nicht so iPhone-Nutzer-Bild? Ich sehe da die Schnittmenge nicht so.
Der ganze Axel-Springer-Konzern ist auf Apple, ne?
Ja, eben. Ihr eigenes Mitarbeiter müssen das kaufen.
Weißt du, die Macher lesen diese Zeitungen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich weiß, ob sie ihre eigene Zeitung lesen. Ist so wie die Frage, ob man seine eigene Podcasts hört.
Ja, ich nicht.
Aber du weißt ja, was darin vorgekommen ist.
Aber ich würde nicht dafür bezahlen.
Ich bin nicht der Einzige, der hier dafür bezahlt. Das müssen wir rausschneiden, das geht nicht.
Aber mal ehrlich, ich glaube, die Schnittmenge, okay, das mag einen geben, ich will jetzt und so weiter und so fort, aber die ist nicht groß.
Also ich finde den Versuch jetzt nicht, ich glaube, sie übertreiben es. Was haben sie denn für eine großartige Wahl? Sie müssen einen klaren Schnitt ziehen. Ich finde, sie ziehen in einer falschen Stelle. Aber dass man für Content unter Umständen auch Geld nehmen sollte, finde ich echt okay. Vielleicht klappt es ja.
Das Produkt muss stimmen, ich glaube nicht, dass das Produkt stimmt.
Das Produkt stimmt in dem Fall nicht. Man muss ja springer lassen, wenn die Sachen in dem Bereich nicht ganz dämlich sind.
Habt ihr schon mal die abgeklickt? Was kriegt man denn davon ab?
Ich kaufe ja nicht irgendeine Springer-App.
Ich habe das eben mal kurz gesucht, ich habe da so nichts gefunden.
Wie funktioniert denn deren Bezahlmodell? Die Zeitung kostet doch nur Geld, weil der Kiosk noch was verdienen muss. Eigentlich würden die doch am liebsten ihre Zeitung sonst verteilen, weil die verdienen an der Werbung in der Zeitung. Und das heißt, die müssten eigentlich gar kein Geld für so eine App nehmen, eigentlich müssten sie nur ihre Werbung in diese App reinpacken.
Ja, das werden sie ja auch tun.
Ja, aber wozu muss man das bezahlen?
Weil man die blöden iPhone-User einfach abziehen kann.
Das hat er auch gesagt, dass die iPhone-User alle zahlwillig werden.
Weil die Werbeeinnahmen einfach wegbrechen. Das ist doch die privaten Nachnacht jetzt nicht umsonst, dass die jetzt langsam auf Pay-TV umsteigen. Das habt ihr sicherlich mitbekommen, dass wenn man Pro 7 und Sat 1 und so was in RTL und HD gucken will, dass man dafür eine Gebühr abdrücken muss. Weil der Werbemarkt einfach einbricht. Natürlich trifft das auch die Zeitung ganz hart. Und zwar die Stellenanzeigen, die existieren einfach nicht mehr. Und dieses Kleinanzeigengeschäft, das vorher ein Schweinegeld gebracht hat, das funktioniert nicht mehr, weil das läuft über andere Plattformen. Also müssen wir vielleicht noch was Neues ausdenken. Sich jetzt vom Leser das Geld zu holen, finde ich erst mal als Idee gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ich denke auch, dass es Modelle gibt, wo das überleben kann. Ich glaube einfach noch nicht, dass Bild-Zeitung dazu gehört. Also ganz ehrlich. Das ist halt einfach kein Qualitäts-Content, wo die Leute wirklich hingehen wegen des Contents. Bild-Zeitung wird nämlich deshalb gelesen, weil alle anderen das auch lesen und man muss halt mitreden können.
Und wegen dem Mädel auf Seite 1?
Aber wenn das irgendwie ein abgesperrter Garten ist, wo das nur über Cache geht, ich glaube es nicht. Aber wir werden es sehen, wir sind skippt.
Ich habe aber noch eine andere Frage zum Thema, wenn wir schon mal dabei sind. Also eigentlich so wie früher hier, wenn ich jetzt sage, der weiße Riese, dann wissen alle gleich, was für Werbung gemeint ist, oder? Weil haben wir im Fernsehen gesehen, wird da irgendwie ewig wiederholt und dann weißt du, was das für ein Produkt ist und wenn du dann irgendwie Waschmittel kaufen gehst, gehst du dann irgendwie einkaufen, siehst den gleichen Scheiß, greifst halt zu, so funktioniert Werbung. Ich meine, kennst du jetzt irgendwas aus dem Internet, was sich dir so aufgedrängt hat, dass du jetzt irgendwie ein Produkt da irgendwie dir...
Ja, dieser Scheiß Drobo.
Hast du schon mal Internet-Werbung über den Drobo gesehen, irgendwie so oft, dass du dich... Ja, von wo? Durch die Werbung oder durch so virales Marketing?
Bei Twitter.
Ich hab das über Blog-Posts irgendwie...
Ja, sprich, du sprachst sie so langsam rum. Aber sonst, ich meine, die ganze Werbung, die siehst, auch bei Google und Zeug, das ist alles irgendwie auch irgendwelche amerikanischen Firmen, die sonst so sitzen, irgendwie bei Spiegel... Weiß nicht, was da ab und zu mal sind, Versicherungen und so. Naja, stimmt schon, da sind natürlich die ganz großen Unternehmen, die weiter ihre Marke da irgendwie pflegen, dann kommt mal Allianzwerbung oder irgendein Kack. Aber so richtig, dass ich jetzt so neue Marken übers Internet kennengelernt habe, hab ich jetzt nicht das Gefühl, so wie ich es früher vom Fernsehen kenne.
Und vor allem keine Jingles.
Deswegen wundert mich so ein bisschen, was die da an... Weil Google verdient sich ja dumm und dem nicht, da an Werbung. Also was da für Geldmengen fließen. Aber ich hab gar nicht so das Gefühl, dass die wirkungsvoll bei mir ankommen. Nicht die Gelder, die Werbung.
Ich meine, das Internet bietet einem natürlich auch Informationskanäle über Werbung hinaus. Ja, die du so im Fernsehen nur eingeschränkt hast. Man lernt es ja auch im Fernsehen, also im Fernsehen gibt es ja auch andere Möglichkeiten, Produkte zu vermitteln, was weiß ich, Testsendungen oder Beraterkram oder so. Was sich da aber auch in Grenzen hält. Da ist aber das Internet super, mega divers. Und ich, ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel diesen Audiomixer, den ich jetzt benutzen will, da hab ich jetzt echt lange rumrecherchiert. Und da war das Netz einfach mal die Quelle, in jeder Hinsicht. Was hat das aber mit der Werbung zu tun? Vor allem diese Produktbewertungsplattformen und diese Preissuchmaschinen, die es da gibt, die spielen eine große Rolle. Die haben extreme Produktdatenbanken über jeden möglichen Scheiß. Und wenn sie gut sind, haben sie auch noch eine sehr diversifizierte Aufspaltung nach, was für Produkteigenschaften haben die. Also wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt einen Fernseher suchst, der jetzt irgendwie eine besonderen Kriterien entspricht, dann bist du einfach mit diesen Portalen viel besser am Start, weil du sagen kannst, ich interessiere mich nur für Fernseher von bis die und die Größe und darf aber irgendwie nicht mehr Strom verbrauchen als und muss irgendwie Full-HD unterstützen und lalalala und so und so viel HDMI-Anschlüsse haben. Da finde ich, dass diese Plattform noch sehr viel mehr Flexibilität bieten könnte, wie man die Suche einschrecken kann, aber das bewegt sich auf jeden Fall voran. Plus du hast dann eben auch noch die ganzen Kommentare von den Leuten, die halt sagen, habe ich es prima oder hatte ich auch mal mich gleich wieder weggeschmissen.
Da muss ich mal sagen, ist mir das aufgefallen und zwar auch bei Amazon jetzt nicht so, aber hier in diesen Reviews bei Apple zum Beispiel, im iTunes, das sind immer die ersten paar Kommentare so von Songs, ja voll nettes Album, dann so ein ganz bisschen so eine ganz Kleinigkeit, die so ein bisschen doch nicht so nett ist, aber so im Großen und Ganzen dazu könnte ich mich irgendwie auch so verlegen und voll entspannen blablabla und das sind immer so die ersten zwei, drei Einträge, also so voll positiv, aber nicht zu übertrieben und danach kommen dann so die echten Kommentare, habe ich das quasi, als wenn da jemand ganz Dolle schummelt. Das hatte ich früher bei Amazon nicht, da hat man ein echtes Gefühl. Bei Amazon, die sagen einfach, wir machen einen mal hier auf normal, die User werden es schon irgendwie richten und das Vertrauen, was die Leute kriegen, ist uns mehr wert, als in den Kommentaren zu schummeln.
Das ist aber jetzt ein sehr subjektiver Eindruck.
Auf jeden Fall. Ja. Dann können die Leute ja mal selber checken. Man sollte auf jeden Fall bei den Kommentaren immer noch ein bisschen weiter lesen, als nur die ersten zwei, drei. Aber jetzt weiche ich mal schon wieder ab. Wir waren jetzt irgendwie bei diesem Bild-App, iPhone Tool. Da sind wir jetzt erst mal irgendwie durch und bei der Werbung auch, ja.
Genau.
Musterhaus, Küchen, Fachgeschäft.
Ja, wo wir schon bei Fernsehen sind, ich hatte die Gelegenheit, so ein...
Ich höre ja nicht Radio.
So ein Apple TV, das ein Freund von mir hat, irgendwie in dem Moment mal selber durch die Software-Update-Prozedur durchzugehen und dann dieses 3.0-Update mal kurz anzugucken. Ja, kann man jetzt... also Software-Update, man muss da so ein bisschen suchen, irgendwie, Einstellungen, wo das so ist. Also er wäre sicherlich irgendwann auch selber mal mit dem Vorschlag hochgekommen, aber ich wusste ja, dass das Software-Update da... Das hat er nicht getan. Also ich musste ihm schon ein bisschen draufstoßen. Keine Ahnung, was da für ein Zyklus gerade eingestellt war oder nicht eingestellt war. Auf jeden Fall hat sich das dann irgendwie alles ganz geschmeidig installiert, wie es eben so die Art ist von diesen Geräten und dann sah nach, sah es halt ein bisschen anders aus als vorher. Sie haben halt jetzt irgendwie noch so ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Ich habe jetzt gar nicht groß den Unterschied zu 2.0, weil damit habe ich nicht so viel gearbeitet, aber... Was ich ganz interessant fand, ist, wie geschmeidig eigentlich so dieses Gerät sein kann, insbesondere wenn man die Remote-Anwendung benutzt. Also man kann ja vom iPhone aus das Ding quasi komplett Fernbedienen über WLAN. Und das ist schon so doof nicht. Sie haben jetzt die Möglichkeit hinzugefügt, auch Radio abzuspielen. Dummerweise allerdings nur die in ihrem bekloppten Radioverzeichnis vorgesehenen. Also du kannst da nicht irgendeine andere URL eingeben. Zumindest ist mir kein Weg offensichtlich geworden, wie das geht, was natürlich blöd ist. Also das geht nicht. Andererseits, du kannst glaube ich schon deine Playlisten da vielleicht auch dann reinbringen und darüber das dann schon auch machen. Also das ist schon jetzt ganz interessant. Und das Ding kann ja auch über AirTunes auf andere spielen und kann auch selber als solche fungieren. Und das geht so ein bisschen schon in die Richtung, wo wir immer mal geredet haben mit so der zentrale Ort, von dem man so seine Musik abspielt. Es müsste ja eigentlich auch gehen, dass man da seinen ganzen Kram draufsüngt. Ich habe jetzt nicht geguckt, ob sie auch dieses Homesharing in dem Sinne irgendwie explizit unterstützen. Naja, die Dinger werden ja aber irgendwie nicht so richtig billig. Also nicht mal so ein bisschen billiger werden, wäre jetzt vielleicht mal ganz interessant.
Also in dem Moment, wo irgendwie da, also ich weiß nicht, ich habe ja auch schon ein paar mal überlegt, ob ich mir sowas, was da passieren müsste, bis ich mir sowas mal kaufe. Und irgendwie vorher, weiß ich nicht, also so richtig reizend tut mich das. Gibt es da, HD gibt es da jetzt aber schon, ne? Also du kannst HD und den ganzen iTunes Store hast du dran. Da ist ja das Hauptproblem, dass es irgendwie zu wenig englische Filme gibt, wie ich finde.
Ja, das ist auch mein Hauptproblem.
Also ich habe da schon echt ein paar Filme ausgeliehen, aber es gibt halt keine Subtitles, wenn es in Englisch gibt, was ich gerne mit Subtitles noch gucke, um das zu verstehen. Aber es gibt halt auch einfach nur einen Bruchteil der Filme in Englisch und dann habe ich irgendwie gestern erst wieder, ich hatte Ali G noch nicht gesehen, da gab es ihn im Store, habe mal kurz auf den deutschen Trailer geguckt und die haben mir echt ohne Scheiß, waren sich nicht zu schade, Ali G mit so Berliner Neukölln-Dialekt zu synchronisieren.
Nein, nein.
Und haben versucht sozusagen diesen Ali G damit zu übersetzen. Das geht einfach nicht.
Wer guckt sich denn so was an?
Schmerzen, ich weiß. Das ist ein Kulturverbrechen. Solange Apple das auch noch fördert, indem sie da so viel deutschen Content synchronisierten anbieten und keine englischen Filme, shoppe ich mir sowas auf jeden Fall schon mal überhaupt sowieso gar nicht.
Irgendwie ist das Apple TV zu sehr auf iTunes Store ausgerichtet. Das ist echt sehr, sehr nervig, finde ich.
Das ist ja eigentlich nichts anderes als ein Hardware-Frontend für das Teil.
Oh, jetzt entledigt sich hier gerade der Chat.
Das ist darüber hinaus, also wenn es das könnte und dann auch einiges mehr, dann wär's echt okay. Aber so ist mir das. Ich hab jetzt irgendwie bei einer CT mal einen Artikel, wie immer, für 100 Euro, so eine HD-taugliche Lösung, die auch über LAN funktioniert und sowas zusammenschrauben kann. Aus so einem Western Digital Gerät und sowas, das hab ich mir jetzt gerade mal gestern bestellt. Mal gucken, was das dann taugt. Aber ich glaube, wenn das irgendwie auch mal ein DIVX vernünftig abspielt, ohne irgendwelche Probleme und sowas, dann wird es nicht tun. Und ein MKV dann, wieso soll das nicht tun?
Also ganz ehrlich, diesen irgendwie AV und MKV-Blödsinn, den müssen sie nun wirklich echt nicht mitgehen. Da finde ich das einfach mal extrem konsequent, was sie da machen, dass sie sagen, nein, wir wollen keine Balkanisierung dieser AV-Formate. Audio-Video-Formate, das ist der Schmerz im Arsch der letzten 15 Jahre. Und jetzt kommt das endlich mal an so einen Punkt, wo man sagen kann, es gibt einen Container und es gibt bestimmte Encodings, die sind jetzt well supported überall. Und du kannst so ein File ausliefern und jemand kann es abspielen, da gibt es einen Standard, da kann man nachschlagen, wie es ist.
Und es läuft auf den meisten Apple-Geräten und sonst auf nichts.
Das ist doch Blödsinn. MPEG-4 läuft mittlerweile überall. Sag mir mal bitte ein Video-Abspielgerät, das nicht in der Lage ist, MPEG-4 abzuspielen.
Windows-Media-Player. Nee, also mir ist das auch egal, solange...
Der Zoom spielt sehr wohl MPEG-4 ab.
Aber eigentlich ist es mir auch total egal, ob der Zoom hat dir spielts ab.
Ja, der Zoom macht das. Ich weiß nicht, wie ist denn das bei Windows 7? Haben die jetzt immer noch keinen MPEG-4-Support drin?
Ich weiß nicht, ob Windows 7 jetzt welchen drin hat. Ich weiß, dass dieses Windows-Media-Center, was auf Windows XP-Base ist, was DVB-T empfängt und was auch DVB-S empfängt. Und DVB-S ist, glaube ich, mittlerweile einfach mal ein MPEG-MP4-Stream. Ist MPEG-2. Aber auf jeden Fall gibt es ja DVB-T2, was ein MPEG-4-Stream ist. Und er kann keine MPEG-Files. Keine MP4-Files. Der macht da sein eigenes Container-Format raus.
Aber mir wäre das eigentlich auch total egal, solange ich halt alle Filme für 1,99 Euro einfach mit einem Klick da klicken kann und in Englisch und mit Subtitles usw. Wenn der ganze Content da liegt, dann gebe ich auch 1,99 Euro aus, statt in die Videothek zu fahren bei Wind und Wetter und mir den dann da zu holen in ordentlicher Qualität oder stundenlang auf Pirate Bay zu googeln und zu suchen.
Du bist jetzt wieder bei Apple TV.
Ja, und dann ist halt auch egal, ob die Apple TV Div X oder sonst was abspielt, weil wenn du das alles so klicken kannst, wäre es für mich vollkommen ausreichend. Dann habe ich überhaupt keinen Bedarf, jetzt erstmal einen Torrent anzuschmeißen und den Film da mühsam runterzupopeln.
Also mir ist die Auswahl einfach zu schwach. Warum man gerade diese amerikanischen Serien, also ich meine, man kann sich South Park, kann man sich selbstverständlich am Tag später, nachdem es in Amerika gelaufen ist, auch auf der deutschen South Park Seite im Original angucken. Im iTunes Store gibt es sowas nicht. Daily Show gibt es die mittlerweile im deutschen iTunes Store. Da gucke ich sehr gerne, aber entweder auf deren Webseite oder ich lade es mir runter. Weil das gibt es alles nur im amerikanischen Store.
Ja, ich verstehe, also dieses magere Angebot ist auch ein echtes Problem und ich frage mich, woran das eigentlich wirklich liegt.
Bestimmt auch irgendwelche komischen Vertriebstils. Ich meine, guck dir an, was die mit den Region Codes machen und irgendwie den gestaffelten Kino-Releases nach Region und so.
Na, weil es nicht sein kann, dass die englischen Serien, sagen wir mal jetzt hier keine Ahnung, Lost oder so, auch einen Tag hier nach einer US-Ausstrahlung im deutschen Store in Englisch irgendwie auftauchen, weil dann würden die deutschen Sender, die die Rechte daran kaufen, haben ja dann Angst, dass dann irgendwie zehn Prozent weniger gucken, weil sie das alle schon in Englisch gesehen haben. Und natürlich wird es so.
Ja, aber so auch so. Das ist ja nicht so, als ob...
Das ist ja illegal und so. Und dann können die besser leben. Dann haben sie wenigstens einen, denen sie die Schuld nicht in die Schuhe schieben.
Dann haben sie ein schönes Argument, was sie dann noch den verkaufen. Das ist exklusiv und ihr seid die Ersten, die es hat. Ja, aber dann sollen sie es doch, meinetwegen auch, dann sollen sie es doch einfach einen Tag später auf Englisch bringen, meinetwegen auch auf RTL. Müssen ja nicht im Fernsehen übertragen, ist mir ja wurscht. Aber ich will Lost sowieso nicht gucken.
Oder sollen halt denen das gleich mit anbieten, dass sie dann irgendwie die Rechte dafür hier für Deutschland kriegen, aber auch für den englischen Content.
Ja, und wenn sie drei Wochen länger brauchen, um das Ganze dann ins Deutsche zu zubereiten, ist das schade.
Jetzt sagen sie hier einfach einen Ami-Account holen. Wenn das mal so einfach wäre, würde ich das auch so folgen.
So mit Leuten, wie ich dann kenne, kannst du mir bitte aus Amerika so eine iTunes-Gutscheinkarte mitbringen, damit ich mir auch mal wieder Content kaufen kann?
Oder eine Prepaid-Kreditkarte kannst du dir auch da kaufen, aber wenn die alle ist, musst du halt auch wieder haben.
Ich habe gehört, dass es dir jetzt auch möglich ist, sich eine iTunes-Account anzulegen, wenn man keine Kreditkarte hat.
Ja, aber irgendwie musst du ja bezahlen.
Also du musst dann glaube ich, in dem Moment, wo du dann kaufst, musst du halt irgendwie eine Kreditkarte angeben und dann musst du aber glaube ich auch eine amerikanische angeben.
Das muss eine amerikanische sein, ja. Oder eben ein amerikanischer Gutschein.
Okay, nochmal kurz zu den Formaten. Es sieht wohl so aus, dass dieses Windows-Media Center in Windows 7 tatsächlich MP4-Support drin hat jetzt. Also, sagt hier ein Windows-Media Center-Flock.
Ich hab ja gar nichts gegen MP4 einzuwenden und so weiter, aber meine Realität sieht nach wie vor ein bisschen anders aus. Und das ist einfach...
Filesharing.
Das ist einfach mal existent.
Guckst du dann keine Filme aus dem Internet hin?
Naja, nur wenn ich dazu gezwungen werde...
Du willst jetzt mal so einen Movie gucken, machst du einen schönen Familienabend mit so einem dicken Film, abends weißt du schon, wie du das machst?
Ja, da hab ich mir schon einige Abende mal mit versaut, mit irgendwie MKV hier und...
Echt, wieso?
Wieso? Weil ich irgendwie nach drei Anläufen mit verschiedenen Playern und so weiter... Das erste Mal lief der Film irgendwie 10 Minuten und dann waren Ton und Bild erst mal 20 Sekunden auseinander. Ja, naja klar, weil das Problem ist auch... Ich hab ja überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass auch andere Sachen ausprobiert werden, sich andere Formate da irgendwie etablieren. Das will ich ja gar nicht kritisieren. Nur die Realität ist einfach die, das Zeug ist einfach anders specified und da arbeiten zu wenig Leute dran, als dass das wirklich stabil wird. Weil AV, Synchronisation und überhaupt Encoder und Metadaten, das ganze Climbim, das ist einfach mal komplex. Da haben die jetzt schon in dem Standardisierungsprozess sehr lange gebraucht, bis das irgendwie halbwegs robust war. Und die Realität ist, wenn du heute so einen AV findest, dann weißt du nicht wirklich, was da drin ist.
AVs gibt es ja so gesehen auch nicht mehr, außer bei irgendwie Billig Content. Also eigentlich ist alles MKV.
Gut, aber für MKV gilt genau das gleiche. Erstens verwenden die da sowieso H264 in 99,999% der Fälle. Hab ich zumindest jetzt noch nicht sehr viel anderes gesehen, dass da irgendwie groß Theora eingesetzt wird. Mag auch sein, aber in der Regel ist MKV H264. Wenn man eh H264 in MPEG-4-Encoding nimmt, warum packt man das nicht gleich noch in ein MPEG-4-Container? Ja, weil es proprietär ist, aber das ist H264 auch. Wenn irgendwie 99% der Datei proprietär ist, dann macht es jetzt dieser kleine, schlanke Filmaufkleber da drum herum auch nicht aus. Das ist doch keine Logik. Und MKV bietet auch nicht mehr als MP4 von den Features her. Da ist also nichts drin, was man da an Mehrwert gewinnt, außer dass man wieder einen anderen Container an der Software supporten muss. Und das gelingt der Software eingeschränkt. Jetzt wird natürlich jeder irgendwie die Hand heben und sagen, nehmt ihr mit dem MP3 kein Problem, nehmt noch VLC, oder nehmt noch MP3, oder nehmt noch dies oder das oder das. Ja. Aber das hab ich dann aber auch gemacht an dem Abend. Der Abend war einfach ruiniert. Ich hab mich irgendwie eine 1,5 Stunden damit beschäftigt, allein diesen Film mal in irgendeiner Variante so abzuspielen, dass er irgendwie nicht einfach aufhört, oder irgendwie der Ton und Bild auseinanderläuft, oder irgendwie die Aspektration nicht stimmt usw.
Du brauchst mal falschherr Nachhilfe.
Ach, Blödsinn. Ich freu mich überhaupt nicht. Ich hab dann auch von allem irgendwie die neuesten Sachen gemacht und mir irgendwie noch die Command-Line... Ja, weißt du. Aber darum will ich mich einfach nicht kümmern.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Ich will einfach sagen, lad mir diesen Scheiß Film und zeig ihn mir an. Und das ist halt das, was dieses Apple TV auch bietet. Ja, aber...
Wenn man halt Filme... Ihr habt ja recht.
Aber das ist das Ding, ja. Es geht ums Angebot. Wenn sie das Angebot fixen, dann ist alles prima. Ja, ich brauch jetzt nicht unbedingt MKV-Support auf diesem Teil. Das löst das Problem auch nicht. Das schafft mir nur wieder ganz neue Probleme.
Nee, das stimmt so nur bedingt. Weil solange sie... Sie konzentrieren es halt zu sehr auf diesen iTunes-Store. Und solange sie diesen Inhalt nicht bieten können, solange sie das nicht draufhaben, müssen sie mir einen anderen Anreizpunkt geben, diese dämliche Box zu nutzen. Und wenn ich so ein Gemischtwarenladen hätte, wo ich ein bisschen... wo ich meinen Gewohnheiten weiterhin erst mal so nachgehen kann, aber dann im Zweifelsfall den komfortableren Weg habe und dafür ein bisschen was bezahle, gern.
Vor allem ist es ja so mit dem iPod. Der iPod kam raus, was haben die Leute da draufgemacht? Ihre Musik von ihren CDs? Hast du natürlich so viel. Also, was hast du gemacht? Hast du von anderen Leuten die Musik von deren CDs draufgemacht? Hat natürlich auch nicht gereicht, weil du willst natürlich noch mehr Musik. Haben sie angefangen bei Napster Musik, Napster war vorher okay. Aber jedenfalls, da kam einfach mal verdammt viel Musik drauf, die nirgends gekauft wurde. Und so hat sich der iPod durchgesetzt. Vielleicht sollte Apple mal drüber nachdenken, dass es ja mit dem Apple-TV vielleicht auch so machen soll. Erst mal anfixen, dass man da alles drauf machen kann und ein bisschen dicht nagen können sie ja später immer noch.
Beim iPod haben sie auch keine Open Source-Codecs benutzt. Das ist ja auch der Punkt, dass sie das halt auch nicht tun werden.
Ja, aber wirklich außer MP3 gab es auch wirklich damals nichts.
Ja, aber sie werden es einfach auch nicht tun. Haben sie eben schon mehrfach gesagt, dass sie irgendwie Open Source-Codecs einfach nicht supporten, weil sie Schiss haben, dass dann irgendeiner aus der Ecke kommt und sagt...
Die können sich doch so Plug-In-Systemen einfallen lassen. Die müssen ja nicht selber supporten.
Das Plug-In-System haben sie ja sogar in Snow Lab hat irgendwie weggelassen. Ich glaube zwar, dass da wieder ein Plug-In-System kommen wird, aber ich glaube halt nicht, dass sie das auf dem Apple TV machen werden. Das ist auch in gewisser Hinsicht gut, weil sonst fangen sie sich einfach da diese digitale Schweinegrippe ein in Form von unterspezifizierten Dateiformaten. Wo nicht klar ist, wer jetzt eigentlich definiert, wie das Teil wirklich aussieht.
Ich werde dir dann hoffentlich beim nächsten Mal Bericht erstatten können, ob mir diese 100-Euro-Lösung nicht vielleicht für mich die bessere Variante ist. Welche 100-Euro-Lösung? Na, mit diesem Western Digital Player mit Netzwerkanschluss.
Die spielen MKV.
Man braucht eine alternative Firma, und dann soll das wohl alles total...
Also ein Mini-Rechner mit Platte oder wie?
Und wenn sie nicht gestorben sind, dann frickeln sie noch.
Ich war ewig lange sehr, sehr glücklich mit Xbox Media Center auf der Xbox, auf der original Xbox. Das war wirklich eine schicke Lösung, du konntest an Videoformaten reinschmeißen, was ging, und die hat das alles abgespielt und ohne Probleme und lief alles super. Aber? Naja, jetzt hab ich einen schicken HD-Fernseher, dann möchte ich auch HD-Content haben, oder ich möchte auf jeden Fall irgendwas haben, was mehr als gab ist.
Das schafft die Kiste nicht.
Das kann der Xbox nicht. Und sie wäre natürlich auch nicht schnell genug für HD-Content. Und eigentlich, wenn es irgendeine gute Box gäbe, auf der das XBMC das mittlerweile, dass es für Mac gibt, dass es für Linux gibt, dass es für alle Plattformen mittlerweile gibt, wenn das irgendwo richtig geil drauf laufen würde, würde ich Yippie-Aye-Aye schreien und würde das sofort kaufen.
Warum läuft es so richtig geil drauf?
Weil es diese kleinen Boxen nicht zu vernünftigen Preisen gibt bisher.
Was kostet denn so eine kleine Box, die die entsprechende Optik hat? Gibt es da Hardware, die einfach nackt daherkommt? Ich bin ein PC und ich habe HDMI und ich habe...
Natürlich gibt es die, aber es sind dann gerne irgendwelche Atom-Chip-Sätze. Die haben dann diese Intel-Grafik drauf und die ist nicht HD-tauglich. Das kannst du eigentlich knicken im Wesentlichen.
Da müsste aber demnächst langsam mal ein Update kommen.
Genau, dann heißen die Nutzen dann im Wesentlichen diese NVIDIA CUDA-Chips heißen die, glaube ich. Die können auch alle HD, solange du die Player-Software einsetzt, die diese HD-Chips unterstützt. Die haben dann nämlich ein extra Chip drin, nur für das Decoding von diesem Zeug. Das heißt, wenn du diesen einen mitgelieferten Player oder meinetwegen Windows-Media-Player da reinpackst, dann ist das alles überhaupt kein Problem. Sobald du da aber einen Linux drauf knallst oder dann eben irgendwie eine Alternativlösung, bist du eigentlich sofort auf dem Trocknen. Dann hast du zwar diesen schönen Chip da drin, aber dann wird er nicht genutzt und es ruckelt wie vorher. Im Gerade war der Witz noch schlecht, plötzlich so. Ist nicht besser geworden. Es gibt da einfach noch keine so richtig geile Lösung, die auch bezahlbar ist und klein und nicht viel Krach macht.
Hier irgendwie Notebook und M-Player und irgendwie...
M-Player Extended.
Aber dann braucht man sich auch nicht mehr über 250 Euro für ein Apple TV beklagen.
Ja, also ich möchte gerne irgendwie so was maximal 200 Euro, 250 Euro, das ist das höchste.
Was kostet das Ding jetzt? Kostet es noch 300 im Apple Deutschland?
Ja, aber auf dem Apple Store läuft das Experiment hier auch nicht vernünftig. Auf dem Apple TV hab ich ja probiert.
Ja, ich meinte jetzt nur so vom Price Range, weil denen 269 Euro offiziell, das ist krass wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen billiger. Sie sind eigentlich schon in diesem Bereich. Und es ist halt noch knifflig da entsprechend Hardware anzubieten, die so powerful enough ist.
Und dann kommen natürlich viele auf die Idee, die packen aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht dieses XBMC da drauf. Was wirklich, also das ist, bin ich der Einzige, der das sagt, das ist wirklich eine grandiose Lösung.
Und nicht XBMC.
Das ist ein Alternativprojekt gewesen, für die Xbox Media Center zu bauen. Also es gab ja so dieses Xbox-Hacking da, um alternative Dashboards zum Laufen zu kriegen und möglicherweise auch mal das Backup eines Spiels spielen zu können.
Eine Privatkopie.
Eine Privatkopie. Und dafür hab ich es tatsächlich nie genutzt, sondern wofür ich es dann genutzt hab, ich hab dann dieses XBMC draufgespielt, das haben irgendwelche Hobby-Programmierer in ihrer Freizeit zusammen gebastelt. Und das ist eine Plattform, du kannst also Videos abspielen, du kannst Audio abspielen, die kann Fotos anzeigen. Die ist über Python massiv erweiterbar, das heißt, du kannst diese ganzen Trailer von der Apple-Seite dir angucken, die haben Wetterbericht drin, die haben RSS-Berea drin, die haben jeden Scheiß direkt drin. Und vieles davon wirklich sehr, sehr schick. Und das Ganze war komplett open source. Das einzige Problem war, dass wenn du das Ganze auf dem... Du konntest es nicht legal kompilieren sozusagen für die Xbox, weil diese Xbox-Development-Kit, die durftest du halt nur zu bestimmten Bedingungen lizenzieren und da gehörte auf einer gehackten Xboxen Media Center starten aus irgendwie mir unerklärlichen Gründen nicht dazu. Und irgendwann sind die dann mal auf die clevere Idee gekommen, dass man dieses Xbox Media Center ja auch auf andere Plattformen konvertieren könnte, portieren könnte. Und seitdem heißt es XBMC, weil das Xbox ist jetzt irgendwie mal rausgeflogen. Und ist einfach so ein kleines App. Das kann man sich auch für Mac einfach runterladen. Und dann hat man so eine Media Center Lösung, die, würde ich mal sagen, Apple TV, also jetzt nicht von der Bedienung her unbedingt, also da ist Apple TV tatsächlich relativ einfach, aber von den Features her Apple TV oder Front Row wirklich um Meilen hinter sich lässt.
Der heimliche Microsoft Fanboy.
Das hat also nichts mit Microsoft zu tun.
Das stimmt, genau, sie haben es ja open source gemacht.
Nee, das ist es. Es hat von Anfang von Abyss gesagt, also es gibt noch, es gab so eine Media Center Extender-Lösung für die Xbox, die total scheiße war. Also die haben auch wirklich ein paar Sachen gemacht, die Microsoft nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt hat, was ich echt irre finde. Also zum Beispiel ist das so, dass der Lüfter bei der Xbox eigentlich die meiste Zeit auf Hochlast läuft, außer du installierst dieses XBMC-Dingsbums, dann regelt der Lüfter-Geschwindigkeit der Temperatur an, sodass du beim Fernsehen oder beim Videos gucken auch dann auch nicht so die ganze Zeit so einen Lärm hast und so was. Also das ist wirklich eine geile Lösung gewesen.
Gut, also...
Gab's halt nur für die klassische alte Xbox.
Es gibt's nicht auf Apple TV.
Doch, es gibt's auf Apple TV. Läuft aber nicht vernünftig.
Next Thema. Jetzt haben wir das glaube ich ausführlich dargelegt.
Erstaunlicherweise.
Habt ihr das gesehen hier mit dem neuen Google Maps?
Gelesen, nicht gesehen.
Also, es gibt diverse Videos auch.
Ich hab auch ein paar Reviews gelesen. Das ist ja...
Also, kurz mal erklären, worum's geht. Google hat angekündigt, dass sie eine neue Version von Maps ausrollen mit Android. Und das Ding macht dann halt komplett, wie immer sagt man so schön im Englischen, Turn-by-Turn Navigation. Mit anderen Worten, komplette Wegführung für im Auto oder womit man auch immer unterwegs ist.
Also nicht nur als Liste, so wie es bisher auch schon geht.
Genau. Sondern so richtig live mit GPS, mit Ansagen, aber auch mit Spracherkennung. Das heißt, du kannst dem Ding sozusagen deine Google Search, wo du den hin willst, einfach auch reinsprechen. Das wird natürlich auf absehbare Zeit erstmal neu auf Englisch funktionieren. Wir wissen das.
Das gibt es für Android 1.6 auch schon, aber nicht auf Deutsch, wie du gerade richtig erwähnt hast.
Und naja, sie holen halt den dicken, fetten Google-Hubba raus. Also sie ballern da irgendwie alles rein, was ihre Alleinstellungsmerkmale sind, insbesondere was natürlich wirklich mega cool ist und wo die anderen echt Probleme haben werden und was auch gut begründet, warum ihre Aktien gleich in den Keller gegangen sind. Sie machen das natürlich gleich mit Street View. Das heißt, du siehst nicht nur irgendwie Karten, sondern du siehst halt so richtig den scheiß 3D-Kram auf deinem Bildschirm.
Du siehst die Spur und stell dich in diese Spur.
Genau. Das heißt, du guckst in deine Umgebung und im Idealfall siehst du auf deinem Display genau dasselbe und dann halt schon so Augmented Reality-mäßig der grüne Pfeil. Fehlt nur noch, dass sie den irgendwie direkt auf die Straße projizieren.
Da liegt immer so ein kleiner Asienüberwachungs-Satellit von Google immer über dir, der kann auch mal einen Laser unterdienen.
Genau, die neuen Google-Navigation-Satelliten, die einfach immer dir den Weg direkt auf die Füße strahlen. Naja, aber das ist natürlich schon geil, weil du kannst halt sofort erkennen, ah, ok, alles klar, das ist ja auch wirklich die Situation, so ist es gemeint.
Oder war das so ein Beispiel, wo du irgendwie eingegeben hast, hier Restaurant XY, und dann so der letzte Schritt war dann dieser Street-View-Blick von genau da, wo du gerade auch ankommst sozusagen auf dieses Restaurant?
Genau. Wir läden ja jetzt auch seit einiger Zeit die ganzen Läden ein, auch hier in Berlin schon sehr erfolgreich. Also wenn du jetzt auf Google Maps guckst, siehst du halt schon so richtig, was da so ein kommerzieller Infrastruktur ist. Noch nicht vollständig, aber ist auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr hilfreich, das ist eigentlich das, worauf man immer gewartet hat. Ja, das ist natürlich ein echter Klopper, muss ich sagen. Also für Android 2.0 ist das ein echter Sales-Anwalt.
Geht aber nur mit Online.
Na ja, gut, aber wir reden von diesen Always-Online-Geräten. Klar, natürlich. Also TomTom funktioniert dann halt auch immer noch ohne das. Und Google setzt halt live voraus, aber sie haben natürlich da auch Möglichkeiten und es ist alles kostenlos. Es kostet halt gar nichts. Du kaufst ja einfach nur dieses Telefon, und du hast das dann einfach. Und du hast halt auch Traffic mit drin. Alles so Sachen, wo du bei TomTom auch noch mal, das heißt, du hast immer die aktuellsten Karten, wo du bei TomTom, ich hab jetzt auch noch so einen TomTom bei mir im Wagen, hab jetzt mal geguckt. Ja, so, die Karte ist jetzt ein Jahr alt. Und wenn ich die jetzt neu kaufe, dann muss ich jetzt erst mal die aktuelle Karte kaufen, das kostet das Update dann 40 Euro, und dann musst du aber damit...
Noch mal 40 Euro bezahlen, damit es für die nächsten 12 Monate bleibt. Und anders kann man es nicht kaufen. Also nur die 40 Euro jetzt aktuell geht gar nicht irgendwie. Also das hab ich ja schon mal vor mehreren Sendungen abgelästert, ist die volle Verarsche.
Das ist wirklich der Finger in der Hand.
Hab ich nicht vor ein paar Sendungen gesagt, Google geht auf Turn-by-Turn-Navigation und Apple hat sich diesen Kartendienst gekauft, um da Google endlich nachtreten zu können?
Ich glaube, du hast gemeint, Apple müsste jetzt auch solche Navi-Lösungen machen.
Die brauchen das demnächst.
Die werden sich das einfach von Google nehmen. Die werden nicht auf Google, die bauen das einfach in ihren Maps ein.
Google macht gerade ein fettes Konkurrenzbetriebssystem auf iPhones. Google und Apple sind so direkte Konkurrenten, wie man sich kaum vorstellen kann. Warum?
Nein, sind sie nicht.
Doch, Apple will...
Google bietet für Telefone ein kostenloses Betriebssystem an. Sie verdienen mit Werbung. Ob die Werbung auf dem iPhone erzeugt wird oder auf dem Android-Telefon, ist denen scheißegal. Die wollen nur alles Mögliche in den Markt haben.
Im Gegenteil, du kriegst ja Geld, wenn du auf deinem Phone irgendwie das Google Zeugs benutzt. Du kriegst ja von Google noch ein bisschen von dem Werbegeld ab. Du hast doch diesen einen längeren Artikel. Und da stand es so drin, dass die Anteil an der Werbung kriegen.
Na klar, also ich meine, Google's ganze Politik ist, Exposure zu kriegen. Alles, was sie machen, sorgt dafür, dass das, was ihr Live-Blood ist, nämlich das Internet, dass das überall hinkommt. Deswegen kaufen sie eigene Internetstrecken, um von den ISPs unabhängig zu sein, natürlich auch aus Performance-Kursen. Deswegen bringen sie sowas raus wie Chrome, Chrome OS, Android und so weiter. Da geht es einfach nur darum, die Technologie nach vorne zu bringen. Deswegen sind sie hinter HTML5. Deswegen bauen sie dieses geile Plug-In für den alten Internet Explorer, wo sie dir ein Kuckucksei, ein Chrome-Views-Ei da reinlegen und die Leute denken, dass sie Internet Explorer benutzen. Tatsächlich benutzen sie eine moderne Rendermaschine. Super geile Idee! Und das ist das, was sie tun. Apple ist für sie insofern überhaupt gar kein Problem, weil Apple macht auch nichts anderes, als die Google-Dienste an alles zu bringen.
Aber Google ist für Apple ein Problem. Google wirbt gerade in Amerika, wenn du auf google.com gehst, ist da unten Werbung für das Droid, für dieses neue Motorola-Telefon mit Android.
Warum sollten sie jetzt auch niemanden davon erzählen?
Also Google wirbt auf seiner Homepage das erste Mal in seiner Geschichte für ein Produkt. Und das ist ein direktes Konkurrenzprodukt zu Apples. Zu Apple?
Für das G1 haben sie auch schon geworben.
Sie haben für das G1 geworben. Ja, eben. Sie bewerben Konkurrenz. Sie sind Konkurrent von Apple. Und Apple will sich das nicht mehr ewig gefallen lassen. Und wenn Google jetzt hier so erzählt, von wegen, ja, wir würden gerne diese Navigation auch aufs iPhone bringen, wenn Apple uns das erlaubt, dann ist das ja schon mal... Dann, dann, dann...
Ich wüsste nicht, warum sie ihnen das nicht erlauben sollten. Das Beste, das kann ihnen doch gar nicht passieren.
Na ja, ich meine, Apple hat ja nun schon andere Google-App-Store abgelehnt.
Ja, aber die hatten...
Die sind nicht abgelehnt, die sind noch nicht fertig.
Ja, aber da ging es.
Aber das ist ein anderer Bereich. Da ging es um Telefonie und das berührt die Verträge mit ihren exklusiven Partnern. Das Problem wird sich, glaube ich, von alleine ausschwitzen und das ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte. Mit diesen Navigationssachen, wenn sie damit ein Problem hätten, dann hätten sie gar keine Navigationssoftware drin. Haben sie aber jetzt. Und das nicht zu knapp. Da ist TomTom, da ist Navigon, da sind andere. Und warum sollte nicht Google dann das da auch mit reinbringen? Da sehe ich überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Ich sehe da tendenziell auch kein Problem, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Apple relativ zeitnah unabhängig werden will von Google in dem Bereich.
Ich glaube eher, dass sie so Apple ein bisschen pushen wollen, dass sie sich da irgendwie Mühe geben, das auch ordentlich in ihre Maps einzubauen.
Und im Zweifelsfall braucht Apple auch einfach, wenn die eine Turn-by-Turn-Lösung machen wollen, wollen sie auch eine haben, wo sie neue Features drin haben. Und die möchten nicht jedes Feature vorher mit Google abquatschen müssen. Die möchten nicht der Konkurrenz das sagen müssen, bevor sie drinstehen.
Aber ich glaube, die haben einfach gar keinen Bock auf so Karten-Business und sich jetzt diese Jacke da anzuziehen.
Ja, das denke ich auch nicht.
Aber warum bekaufen sich dann Kartendienst?
Ja, die machen jetzt nicht ein eigenes Maps auf.
Das ist nach wie vor einfach ein totales Gerücht, dass es sich dabei um einen Kartendienst handelt. Das handelt sich da um eine Firma, die irgendwie Orte erfasst hat. Aber nicht Karten gemacht.
Also hier so ein Maps-Dienst, das ist so weit weg von Apples Core Business, wie es überhaupt nur geht so.
Natürlich, ich glaube auch, dass sie die Leute nur gekauft haben, einfach wegen Hirn. Die brauchten einfach Leute, die sich auskennen und die sie da machen. Also gar keine Frage. Ich meine, das ist ja nur ein No-Braner. GEO ist einfach eins der großen Businesses der Zukunft in all seinen Ausprägungen. Apples Markt ist, Geräte verkaufen. Googles Markt ist, Werbung zu verkaufen. Da mag es hier und da mal ein bisschen Reibung geben, aber im Großen und Ganzen sind die einfach des Jungen. Ich würde sagen, wo die sehr viel mehr Konkurrenz sind, das hat damit nichts zu tun. Das sind so Sachen wie Mobile Me und Services und so. Wo Google alles schön billig bis sehr billig, also kostenlos bis ein bisschen billig anbietet. Und Apple versucht da so eine Premium-Rate-Geschichte zu etablieren, was ihnen aber irgendwie nicht so gelingt. Da werden sie sich sicherlich die Köpfe anräumen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es in diesem Maps-Bereich ist. Na, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall Tatsache ist, es gibt jetzt dieses Droid, beziehungsweise in Deutschland wird es ja Milestone heißen.
Und erstmal ohne Kartenlösung, ohne Navigationslösung sein?
Haben Sie das so gesagt, ja?
Es gibt eine Probeversion der Motorola-eigenen Navigationslösung. Es gibt dieses Turn-by-Turn Navigation, nicht für Europa.
Ja gut, aber es wird irgendwie kommen.
Es wird kommen, natürlich.
Wenn es nicht jetzt gleich kommt...
Wir haben wahrscheinlich die Daten einfach für Europa noch nicht.
Ich war übrigens sehr überrascht von diesem Motorola-Ding. Also, weil ja auch... Ich... Der Meinung war, dass Motorola da auch schwer angeschlagen sein wird von dieser ganzen iPhone-Attack. Das ist es ja auch. Also, sie haben ja wirklich keine gute Zeit gehabt. Sie gehen jetzt allerdings massiver und offener auf Android zu, als ich es so für möglich gehalten habe mit diesem Gerät. Ich meine, es gibt so ein paar Reviews. Das muss man erstmal in der Hand gehabt haben, um sich da wirklich eine Meinung zu bilden, ob das nun wirklich was taugt oder nicht.
Aber die Reviews sind ja gerade zu euphorisch.
Ja, aber diese Reviews waren bisher offiziell zu jedem Produkt irgendwie passende Euphorie.
Ja, natürlich findest du zu jedem Produkt passende Euphorie, aber auch zu Windows Mobile.
Das ist jetzt halt mal wieder ein neuer iPhone-Killer.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wobei das ja schon immer seltener passiert ist, irgendwie mal wieder ein neuer iPhone-Killer.
Das Groid ist wirklich ein spannendes Gerät.
Diesmal wirklich der iPhone-Killer.
Das ist natürlich kein iPhone-Killer. Ich glaube, das behauptet ja auch niemand, aber es ist einfach ein gutes Telefon.
Oh, wo Reisen macht es nicht Spaß.
Reisen, ja klar.
Also ich bin weiter in der Meinung, dass solange die Hersteller irgendwie, also der Hardware-Hersteller und der Software-Hersteller nicht der gleiche sind, wird das nichts.
Ja, aber diese Meinung ist halt ungefähr immer widerlegt worden durch Microsoft. Ich meine, Microsoft hat schon immer...
Aber die gibt es ja auch nicht mehr lange.
Dieses Windows, meinst du, das hat sich bald erledigt, das Thema. Die haben jetzt 20 Jahre den PC-Markt beherrscht.
Aber irgendwann ist es auch mal Ende. Also guck dir an, Apple kam wirklich aus dem Nichts.
Ja, Apple hat eine grandiose Nischenlösung.
Aber die Nische wird immer größer.
Die Mac-Nische. Also Apple kann einen bestimmten Bereich, einen sehr großen Bereich, aber einen bestimmten Bereich, also einen definierten Bereich, können sie sehr gut abdecken und können da sehr tolle Produkte bauen. Aber sehr viele andere Bereiche, da findet Apple schlicht und ergreifend nicht statt.
Ja, Pöbelstil zum Beispiel.
Also ich meine, sobald du irgendwie in den Embedded-Bereich gehst oder sobald du irgendwie auf die Set-Up-Box gehst, um jetzt mal dabei zu bleiben mit dem Apple-Team.
Ja, aber da findet auch kein Microsoft statt.
Wie findet da Microsoft statt?
Im Embedded-Bereich.
Ja klar, mit Windows CE.
Gibt's doch gar nicht mehr.
Natürlich.
Ja, und was treibt das irgendwie nennenswertes außer Lufthansa Entertainment Systeme?
Jeder dritte Geldautomat, wahrscheinlich jeder Geldautomat in Deutschland, wird von einem Windows-Betriebssystem betrieben.
Aber das ist doch kein Riesenmarkt, ich bitte dich.
Also auf jeden Fall hat Microsoft einen Marktanteil mit Windows von wie viel?
Wie viel über 90 %?
Wie hoch ist der Marktanteil in Geld verdienen davon? Das ist doch der Punkt. Ich meine, die Diskussion hatten wir jetzt schon 1000 Mal, da hatten wir die ganze Zeit die Köpfe gegeneinander. Das müssen wir jetzt gar nicht aufwärmen. Ich finde das jetzt auch überhaupt nicht so wichtig und so entscheidend. Ich meine, wir waren jetzt gerade im Mobilfunk-Bereich, und ich denke, wir sind uns alle einig, dass Microsoft da jetzt erstmal raus ist.
Da ist Microsoft erstmal raus.
Es gibt jetzt einfach RIM, Apple und Android, und das ist das, wo die spannenden Sachen passieren werden in den nächsten zwei bis drei Jahren.
Und im Android-Bereich werden mit Abstand die meisten neuen Telefone rauskommen, das heißt nicht die besten, aber da wird es sehr, sehr viele geben. Das ist ja jetzt schon offensichtlich. HTC waren die allerersten. Motorola hat jetzt sehr spannende Geräte auf dem Markt. Sony Ericsson hat jetzt gerade eins vorgestellt, dieses Xperia da irgendwas.
Sony Ericsson hat jetzt auch ein Android-Phone angekündigt.
Steht in dieser Wave, Public Wave, im M037 drinnen und drinnen.
Dann muss es ja stimmen.
Sony Ericsson hat dieses Gerät angekündigt. Es gibt Videos auf jeden Fall davon und in Aktionen. Ich glaube, sie haben es jetzt schon offiziell angekündigt. Es gibt sehr Samsung-verkauft Geräte. Es gibt da schon einige mittlerweile. Das ist ein spannender Markt. Da werden schöne Geräte dabei sein. Dieses Droid könnte in einigen Bereichen, zumindest von der Hardware her, dem iPhone, doch ziemlich überlegen. Display-Auflösung und so was alles. Das Betriebssystem scheint ja nun auch nicht schlecht zu sein, besonders diese neuen Kommunikationslösungen, die sie eingebaut haben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch das mal angeguckt habt. Ohne dass jetzt einer von uns tatsächlich auch mal so ein Android-Phone in täglicher Benutzung hat, kann man nicht...
Das ist mein Zuhause, ja. Ach so.
Du traust dich damit nicht her.
Nee, das ist mit Android 1.6, das ist HTC Magic. Das ist tatsächlich kein Vergleich mit dem iPhone. Das ist wesentlich schlechter. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie das mit Android 2.0 wirklich aufgeholt haben. Aber der Abstand wird kleiner und es bietet Bereiche. Wenn ich hier dran denke, dass das Google-Adressbuch automatisch abgeglichen wird, dass das Facebook automatisch bei Bedarf mit meinem Facebook-Account abgeglichen wird, dass ich eine Instant-Messaging-Lösung von vornherein drinne habe, wovon ich bei Apple nach wie vor nur träumen kann, wenn ich nicht eine Menge Geld für ausgehe. Es gibt wirklich Bereiche, da ist dieses Android dem iPhone ziemlich überlegen und es gibt Bereiche, wo sie total abgekotzt sind. Das ist der Browser, etc.
Was soll das SDK im Übrigen? Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das bei 2.0 deutlich verbessern.
Zum SDK habe ich ja ganz unterschiedliche Sachen gehört. Die einen schwärmen davon, die anderen sind total...
Im Vergleich zum iPhone-SDK, wo man natürlich auch sagen kann, was man will. Das ist ja auch... Zum Beispiel das iPhone-SDK, was ich bisher gesehen habe, da kann ja Dennis mich gleich noch mal korrigieren. Das ist auf jeden Fall noch nicht so umfassend und ausführlich und bis ins kleinste Detail präzise, wie bei einem normalen Desktop-Coucour. Da gibt es halt immer mal so Stellen, wo dann irgendwie so drin steht. Auf dem iPhone müsste es so sein, aber könnte auch irgendwie nicht so richtig. Also waren schon so ein paar Stellen in der Doku, wo man so dachte, hä, das ist jetzt aber hier nicht so Apple-Niveau. Doch, das hab ich schon selber gesehen bei irgendwelchen Geo-Location-Services. Keine Ahnung, aber auf jeden Fall prinzipiell ist das halt schon ziemlich gut. Egal. Auf dem Android-SDK, da haben wir halt auch hier in der Firma ganz viele sitzen, da ist halt irgendwie das SDK um einiges schlechter dokumentiert. Und dann gibt es halt auch so Sachen wie, sie haben halt keine eigene HTTP-Library, sondern sie haben irgendwie Apache, HTTP, irgendwas. Aber dann auch nicht die aktuellste Version, sondern eine von vor zwei Jahren. Dann hast du halt irgendwie einen Wust von zusammengeklaubter Software und Libraries in diesem SDK. Man ist halt auch alles andere als konsistent. Also in der Hinsicht ist zum Beispiel das SDK wohl ziemlich anstrengend. Und dann gibt es halt auch ganz viele Sachen, wo du kannst halt in dem einen Kontext Bilder aufmachen oder in die Gallery speichern. Im anderen Kontext geht es nicht, aber es steht auch nicht drin, warum. Oder so ganz viele Sachen, wo es auf einmal einfach im SDK so Features nicht gibt und du die von Hand selber implementieren musst, die eigentlich so das Gewöhnlichste von der Welt sind, wie eben zum Beispiel ein Bild in der Gallery speichern. Das wird jetzt auch von Version zu Version besser. Also die Schmerzen der Entwickler da bei uns in der Firma, die werden auch kleiner. Aber das ist wohl auf jeden Fall noch so ein Punkt, wo sie auch ganz schön noch zu tun haben.
Aber da kann man ja mit, also mit Android ist ja es schöner, man kann mit regulären Java rangehen und man muss ja nicht Objective-C erst großartig lernen.
Gut, aber die C-Programmierer, also die guten C-Programmierer kommen mit Objective-C auch erstaunlich gut. Klar, habe ich jetzt live und in Farbe miterlebt.
Na ist doch nochmal Objective-C.
Also ich habe hier einen, der vorher noch nie Objective-C gecoded hat, von einem Entwickler von uns erstmal alle Warnings und so gefixt und hat sich da sofort zurechtgefunden. Also, scheint auch zu gehen.
Okay, also ich habe ja mit diesen eckigen Klammern überall noch ein bisschen auf die Nüsse.
Aber ich meine, wenn man sich an eckigen Klammern irgendwie schon...
Die Syntax ist gewöhnt. Flame War, hier, Chapter... Ich habe nix gegen, ich habe nix. Ich habe ja mal nach dem letzten Podcast...
Flame War, Programmiersprachen, bitte.
Nach dem letzten Podcast bin ich ganz heiß gewesen, bin sofort in den Laden gefahren, habe mich noch mal in Ruby ein bisschen reingearbeitet und habe mir mal Mac Ruby angetan. Es ist noch rough an den Ecken, es ist noch lang nicht fertig. Aber ich habe mir mal diesen Kurs daruntergeladen, gibt es einen Videokurs auf der Mac Ruby-Seite für 9 Dollar. Und der ist wirklich geil. Ich habe mir den angeguckt und muss man sagen, ich habe mit Ruby schon mehrfach mal reingeguckt, weil immer so, ja, ist auf jeden Fall eine nette Sache, aber ich hatte nie so einen Anwendungsfall. Und wenn man keinen Grund hat, eine Sprache zu lernen, dann macht man es eigentlich auch nicht, wenn man jetzt nicht gerade extrem viel Zeit hat. Genauso mit Coco, das habe ich auch schon mal. Da habe ich mir angefangen, dieses Hildegard Buch zu lesen. Buch zu lesen und auch da im Wesentlichen das Gleiche. Ja, ist eine schöne Sache. Aber ja, ich habe jetzt auch nicht so die konkrete Idee. Ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht gleich hier sonst was aus dem Boden stampfen, sondern für ein kleines App-Di-Idee. Und jetzt habe ich das quasi nochmal in der Verbindung gesehen. Und zum einen ist dieses Video tatsächlich sehr gut gemacht, weil es bietet echt einen guten Einstieg sowohl in die Coco-Programmierung und der Ruby Code ist jetzt so simpel, dass ich als ziemlicher Anfänger da problemlos mit klar gekommen bin. Und es werden auch ein paar Zusammenhänge besser als in diesem Hildegard-Buch erklärt. Sie weisen explizit nochmal darauf hin, dass man das auch lesen soll und dass das nach wie vor eine gute Standardlektüre ist und dass das erweitern soll. Aber so für einen allerersten Einstieg ist dieses Video echt besser als das Coco-Buch.
Da ist ja auch ein Video, oder?
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das Video geht ja nur 15 Minuten. Fast eine Stunde. Echt? Ach ja, stimmt, stimmt, das war das andere. Aber da werden halt einfach so ein paar Zusammenhänge und dann macht es auf einmal irgendwie Sinn und man weiß jetzt, ok, das meinen sie jetzt mit Delegate und das ist jetzt hier mit irgendwie, so weiß ich nicht, irgendwie in dem Buch ist das alles schon so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, trockener, trockener, ja.
Mehr aus C-Sicht, also das ist tatsächlich, das ist so, wenn man aus der…
Der Hilligard-Buch ist halt wirklich für Leute, die vorher gar nichts konnten, glaube ich.
Nö, sie setzten explizit C-Kennnnisse voraus.
Ja, nicht so wirklich.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, aber es war halt irgendwie für so ein…
Ist schon sehr, sehr für Einsteiger, sagen wir mal so.
Ja, ist schon sehr, sehr für Einsteiger, aber es ist, aber gerade die Delegates, was Symbols sind, erklärt, also Symbols erklärt, werden im Kokobuch auch sehr, sehr technisch erklärt, wie die funktionieren. Das wird in dem Video, wird das nur angeschnitten, aber so angeschnitten, dass man es versteht. Das ist zum Beispiel lustig. Also es geht nicht wirklich in die Tiefe, aber erklärt es auf einem Niveau, dass man erst mal gut mitarbeiten kann, wo man sich bei diesem Hilgat-Booters so eher am Kopf kratzt, und sagt Brrrrp.
Genau.
Peepcode, Mac-Ruby, gibt's da ein Video. Warte mal, da gucken wir noch. Also ich hab dann dann nach, weil's auf dem iPhone eben kein Mac-Ruby gibt, hab ich ja auch dann sozusagen die Lehren aus diesem Mac-Ruby-Video auch gleich in Objective-C anwenden können, wo ich dann irgendwie einfach so geschneit hab, was jetzt so genau mit dem Model-View-Controller wieder dann sozusagen in der Objective-C-Welt aussieht.
Und hat gar nicht wehgetan.
Und man schreibt in diesem 1-Stunden-Video einen kleinen Twitter-Client. Und der ist, das macht echt Laune. Also diese Ruby ist schon eine sehr schön kompakte Sprache, mit diesen ganzen Rangers zu arbeiten und so, das macht wirklich Spaß und das passt eigentlich grandios zu dieser API. Das ist wirklich toll. Also ich bin sehr angefixt davon und ich hoffe, dass es weitergeht. Was leider noch nicht so schön ist, ist die Xcode, die Autocompletion, die funktioniert. Die ist für dieses, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, für dieses Ruby-Coco noch. Und liefert darum eine falsche Syntax leider, die man dann per Copy und Paste, das ist wirklich relativ unangenehm. Aber darüber hinaus ist es wirklich eine großartige Sache und ich hoffe mal, dass wir diese eine Sache noch relativ bald gefixt kriegen. Bestimmt im Detail gibt es da bestimmt noch eine Sache, die ganz furchtbar ist. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich damit keinen Code ausliefern muss, dann muss mein kleines Testprogramm als Fat Binary 120 MB groß sein.
Da hast du dir dann aber das ganze Mac-Ruby noch mit reingezogen.
Also damit es plattformenunabhängig läuft.
Genau, das wird aber auch noch alles. Aber was ich eben auch als Fazit da so rausziehe, ist eigentlich, dass es wirklich extrem gut zusammenpasst. Dieses Ruby und dieses Cocoa, das macht echt um einiges mehr Freude als Objective-C.
Wie gesagt, am Ende ist ja auch immer das Framework und nicht die Sprache.
Aber es fügt sich einfach gut zusammen. Die haben gute Arbeit geleistet, das Cocoa da an das Ruby ranzuflanschen oder andersherum oder beides zusammen. Das haben wir einfach echt schön.
Schätzt ihr überhaupt irgendwas, zu unserer Ausführung vom letzten Mal noch irgendwas Neues hinzuzufügen? Passiert da gerade irgendwas?
Die Schrauben nach wie vor, ich glaube, der Release-Candidate von der 05 ist noch nicht draußen, sind noch die ganze Zeit fleißig am Schrauben. Aber ich würde mal tippen so vor...
Aber es läuft sozusagen auf diese 05-Release irgendwie hinaus.
Genau, das wird erstmal der nächste große Meilenstein. Mit viel Performance, viel Verbesserung und mehr Features. Also, ja. Ich denke mal, im November wird das noch kommen.
Ja. Nächstes Thema? Du hast die Maus in der Hand. Ich könnte noch was erzählen über den Apple Store. Ja, was wollen wir zuerst machen?
Ich hab noch ein gejailbreaktes iPhone.
Und was hast du denn?
Du hast auf jeden Fall keine Schoki mehr im Kühlschrank. Habe ich gerade mit grauen Fenster bestellt.
Du hast unsere Schoki aufgefressen? Ich glaube, ich habe sie noch nicht wie beim letzten Mal.
Also erstmal habt ihr die fast komplett weggefressen. Und das Schlimmste ist, man hat das auch noch die ganze Zeit live gehört. Es gab so diverse Kommentare, die ich sehr gut nachvollziehen kann.
Ah, verstehe, du hast sie versteckt und wir kriegen die nach der Sendung, Toi.
Wir müssen uns irgendwie was anderes einfallen lassen. Ich denke, ihr habt eine gepflegte Brotzeit, aber dieses komische Schoki-Geschmatze, das geht überhaupt nicht. Da werden jetzt einige Hörer gerade ganz ordentlich nicken.
Naja, ich habe die Kommentare auch gelesen, ich sehe das auch ein, aber wie willst du mit der Brotzeit machen?
Brot? Wurst?
Ich könnte ja jetzt was essen.
Ja, ich auch, ich habe meinen Magen knurrt.
Eigentlich müsste man erstmal eine dicke, fette Chili-Kon-Kane irgendwie hinstellen, sich richtig schön vollfressen und dann podcasten. Und ich sage euch, da werden wir noch hinkommen, wenn ich hier erstmal meine ganzen anderen Hürden genommen habe.
Aber wozu eine Küche? Du hast doch Telefon.
Was? Malst du jetzt wieder so Pizza-Bringdienst oder so? Ja, aber das ist doch blöd.
Ja, hast du ja recht.
Wir werden mal demnächst ein ordentliches Brot mitbringen.
Genau, das kommt irgendwie alles.
Das kann ich machen, weil ich habe ja so einen Bäcker, der im Steinhofen selber bäckt und so.
Ich wollte einfach Frühstück.
Ich war in Hamburg. Soll ich einfach mal die Applestore-Schichte erzählen? Ich war im Applestore.
Du bist nicht Appstore, sondern Apple Store.
Es gibt jetzt auch in Hamburg Applestore?
Ja, schon eine kleine Weile. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie lange es her ist. Einige Wochen, Monate, zwei oder so.
Das war jetzt der zweite, der erste war in München.
Genau, und demnächst wird ja wohl einer in Frankfurt eröffnet werden. Und es gibt auch schon eine Gerüchtelage für einen neuen Applestore in Berlin auch. Eine dünne Gerüchtelage. Wer war das? Irgendwie Berliner Morgenpost? Irgendwie so was war es. So ein Kurier oder Berliner Kurier.
Und wo sollte der sein? Das wurde nicht gesagt. Ich vermute aber immer noch... Ich glaube, die Ecke ist eigentlich ganz cool da.
Nein, ich wette mit dir Kudamm.
Echt?
Ich fürchte auch West-Berlin.
West-Berlin definitiv und Kudamm, das ist einfach mal der Ort, wo am meisten Geld ausgegeben wird. Ich würde eher sagen...
Ich würde eher sagen... Friedrichstraße oder Unter den Linden.
Würde schon passen, aber ich glaube, die BME auf West-Berlin...
Hast du da mal eingekauft?
Ich hab auch noch nie am Kudamm eingekauft.
Ja, aber Friedrichstraße im Vergleich zum Kudamm, das ist wirklich... Nein, das ist ein Grabbeltisch im Vergleich zum Kudamm. Ja, natürlich, klar. Die werden sich da nicht präsentieren. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich hab da mal um die Ecke gewohnt, ich kenn die Gegend so. Ich bin dann immer mal wieder hoch und runter gegangen. Und Friedrichstraße ist weit, weit, weit weg von diesem... Ich meine, es gibt diesen Mythos, das wäre irgendwie ein Einkaufsmal, aber wenn du da langläufst, da herrscht einfach totale Elend. Du weißt, in jedem dieser Blöcke hast du irgendwelche komischen unterirdischen Shopping-Malls, wo du dich da in die Dunkelheit begeben kannst und da sind dann einfach wirklich so aller wels Läden mit sehr eingeschränkten... Klar, es gibt hier und da auch mal ein bisschen was teureres, das ist nicht so der Punkt, aber es ist definitiv nicht so eine Brand-Meile wie jetzt der Kudam. Und da ist einfach mal... da wird die Kohle ausgegeben.
Da haben sie halt alle ihre großen Stores, Nike, Adidas und so, die haben da alle ihre Flagship-Stores. Oder wie heißt die Straße da die andere? Ja, das ist halt alles so ein KDW in diesem...
Ich dachte, die Ecke wäre einfach... Ich dachte, die würde jetzt demnächst gesprengt werden, weil da eh nichts mehr los ist.
Nee, nee, da geht's hoch her.
Seitdem Zoo jetzt irgendwie... Haben die da noch irgendwie einen Bahnhof?
Übrigens ist mein Internet gerade weg.
Ja, das ist... Der Zoo kommt da wirklich voran. Ich meine, das ist nach wie vor touristisch sehr interessant. Und... Die werden... Die bauen da jetzt auch gerade dieses neue... Wie heißt das? Zoofenster? Dieses neue Hochhaus? Also da wird gerade investiert. Die haben dieses Haus abgerissen. Ist ja auch nicht so wichtig. Er wird irgendwo in Berlin aufmachen und ich war in Hamburg.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Ist aber auch am besten, oder?
Ja, ein langer Anlauf ist manchmal auch gar nicht so schlecht. Na ja, ich bin dahin gefahren. Ich hatte was anderes zu tun in Hamburg. Und deswegen war ich dort. Und ich hatte aber noch einen kleinen Problemfall, nämlich mein altes iPhone 3G. Das hatte zwei Probleme. Problem 1 war, dass mein Kopfhörerausgang irgendwie nicht mehr funktionierte. Das werde ich gleich erzählen. Und das andere Problem war, dass ich mich dummerweise im Wald mit dem iPhone in der Hosentasche mit dem Glas nach unten auf irgendeinen Stein gesetzt habe und das war es dann mit dem Bildschirm. Das heißt, das Ding war gesprungen. Und mit dem Gerät in der Tasche dachte ich mal, fährst du mal dahin. Das ist natürlich ein Italien-iPhone und so. Ansonsten wäre es eigentlich gar nicht so das Thema gewesen, da wäre ich zu welchen Provider auch immer hingeladet. Aber ich wollte halt einfach mal gucken, wie so die Experience ist. Warte, warte, es ist ein Italien-iPhone.
Achso, dein erstes 3G war auch aus Italien?
Und ich wollte halt einfach mal so sehen, wie so die Apple Store Experience ist. Ich muss dazu sagen, hab ich auch schon gesagt, Apple Store ist jetzt so für mich nichts Neues. Ich hab schon ein paar kennengelernt, auch den in München. Und eins finde ich immer wieder erstaunlich und das war auch jetzt wieder so, du wirst da einfach extrem zuvorkommend bedient. Also das ist einfach so, mit dir umgegangen wird jetzt so rein menschlich, persönlich, das ist einfach mal ass rein. Da haben die ein super Training und ich frage mich, wie die diese Ruhe weg haben. Man hat das ja gerade in Berlin selten genug, dass, ja, du kommst irgendwo rein und so und dann hast du das Gefühl, du kannst auch gleich wieder gehen. Die einfach nur mit so einem Blick anschauen, so wie, sie haben doch ihr Produkt, gehen sie doch wieder, oh Gott, schon wieder ein Kunde, jetzt muss ich wieder arbeiten und so.
Kann ich gar nicht meinen Solitär weiterklecken.
Also das hast du schon mal überhaupt nicht, du wirst halt auch gleich angesprochen und so. Ich bin allerdings relativ zielstrebig zu diesem Genius-Barder gelaufen, wo ich mich ja auch vorher im Web angemeldet hatte, das heißt, ich hab mir einen Termin geben lassen, ich war 20 Minuten zu früh, da wurde ich dann gebeten nochmal ein bisschen zu warten, weil wäre ja noch jemand anders dran und so, immer alles total nett. Naja, dann kam ich da irgendwie hin erzählte sozusagen von meinem Problem. Bei dem Kopfhörer, das war dann schon fast ein bisschen peinlich, irgendwie stellte sich heraus, der ist gar nicht kaputt, den hat er dann irgendwie einfach mal gereinigt. Dazu braucht man aber einfach mal das entsprechende Gear. Er hat dann einfach ein Otoskop genommen. Was ist das? Das ist ja was ein Otoskop ist. Das ist das, womit der Ohrenarzt euch ins Ohr reinguckt. Diese Lampe und Lupe in einem. Was du sozusagen einfach nur so reinsteckst und dann geht das Licht hin und du hast einen Lupe und guckst halt einfach auf das Teil drauf und dann siehst du mal, was da drin ist. Sowas haben die sowieso, weil sie das natürlich brauchen, um rein zu gucken, ob die Feuchtigkeitssensoren angeschlagen sind.
Wäre es nämlich sonst rot, wenn...
Genau, der wäre rot und es gibt einen oben im Headphone-Jack und es gibt einen unten im Dock. Und er hat dann auch an beide Stellen reingeguckt und da war dann irgendwie weißer Punkt zu sehen, also nicht rot und von daher war schon mal klar, dass dieses Gerät keinen Wasserschaden hatte. Außerdem hat er dann festgestellt, dass meine Kopfhörerbuchse eine Art und Weise verdreckt war, wie ich selber nicht für möglich gehalten habe. Der hat dann irgendwie mehrere Kilogramm Schleim da irgendwie rausgezogen mit seiner Pinzette und danach funktioniert es wieder ganz tadellos. Das war so ein bisschen peinlich, weil ich dachte ja nun wirklich, da wäre irgendwie ein Defekt dran, aber es war einfach nur verharzt. Aber ich hätte nie geglaubt, wie viel Dreck sich in so einem Loch sammeln kann. Das war wirklich absurd.
War ja so ein bisschen peinlich, hoffe ich. Ein echtes Dreckloch.
Ja, da sagen wir mal so, ich habe da schon mal so ein bisschen rumgekratzt und so, aber man sieht da ja auch irgendwie gar nichts drin. Ich war mir einfach irgendwie vollkommen unklar an da drüber und es war jetzt auch, weiß ich nicht, ich hatte jetzt so eine Pinxette, die da reinpasst, hatte ich irgendwie nicht. Keine Ahnung, man hätte das schon irgendwie hinbekommen, aber ich habe es halt einfach nicht getan. War ja auch egal. Ich wollte ja auch jetzt ganz bewusst diesen Apple Store als solchen einfach mal testen. Ich kam einfach an so, hier ist ein Problem, was könnt ihr da machen? Und dann hatte er erstmal kommentarlos dieses Ding irgendwie gereinigt und so live vor mir. Ja, ja. Und das erste Problem war da sozusagen schon mit gelöst. Vorher allerdings habe ich ihm natürlich erstmal gesagt, wie die Voraussetzung ist, nämlich dass ich der Meinung bin, dass dieses Gerät an zwar mindestens einer offensichtlichen Stelle, nämlich dem Display, im Arsch ist und vielleicht eben auch noch dieser Kopfhörerausgang und dass das Ding eben aus Italien ist. Ob er mir denn da helfen könnte? Ah, meint er, schwierig. Weil ist ja irgendwie Exklusivvertrag mit T-Mobile und eigentlich und so. Und wenn das Ding halt wirklich defekt ist, dann könnte er mir halt nur ein gesimploktes T-Mobile-Handy geben und andere haben sie ja nicht und sozusagen auf Direktaustausch. Die sind da auch eher, wir tauschen mal schnell, als dass sie da irgendwie reparieren.
Warte, warte, also das heißt...
Das war jetzt erst mal so seine Die-Fault-Ansage.
Wenn es so richtig kaputt gewesen wäre, dann hättest du es zwar schon getauscht, aber du hättest dann ein gelocktes bekommen ohne...
Nee, er hätte es nicht getauscht, denke ich. Also das glaube ich nicht, dass er mir das... Einerseits sagte er, dass er eben nichts anderes habe und andererseits natürlich auch, dass eben meine Garantie sozusagen in Deutschland nicht gilt, sondern eben nur in Italien gilt. Das war jetzt erstmal so sein Standard-Disklaimer als Generalansage. Gut, damit habe ich auch gerechnet. Das habe ich alles ruhig zur Kenntnis genommen. Und ich stand da halt einfach nur und schaute einfach...
Was er so macht...
.aufgeschlossen und ich wollte einfach nur mal gucken, wie viel mir hier geholfen werden konnte und war einfach auch... Habe auch damit gerechnet, dass er sagt, du hast italienisches Nutentelefon, widerlicher Kunde, geh raus. Aber nichts davon fand statt, sondern er hat ja irgendwie erst mal diesen Kopfhörer das Problem sozusagen erst mal gelöst durch Reinigung. Und dann kam er dann sozusagen auf das eigentliche Problem dieses gesprungene Display. Und na ja, meinte er, er könnte hier schon irgendwie... Hat er das Wort Kulanz benutzt? Weiß ich nicht. Aber er meinte, das könnte er halt schon tauschen. So, also er könnte dieses Display abnehmen und ein neues Display draufsetzen.
Also das Glas.
Das Glas, genau.
Das tat es ja aber mit dran, ne?
So eine Einheit. Davon gehe ich aus. Das ist so eine komplette Einheit. Also die ist jetzt auch nicht ohne Wert. So, er meinte aber...
Das sind bei ihm 40 Euro.
Ja, aber die komplette Service-Einheit. Ich tausche dir das Glas von deinem iPhone, gib's da zum Festpreis.
Von?
199 Euro.
Okay, das ist genauso viel wie im T-Punkt. Aber im T-Punkt kannst du's natürlich vergessen. Da geht's nur für mit Gelocten.
Aber da gab's irgendwie Flexibilität. Weil ja nun, sagen wir mal, dieses Glas jetzt als solches... Was haben Sie da jetzt auch schon zu verlieren gehabt? Das Glas funktioniert auf jedem iPhone genauso gut. Und er hat mir dann bloß nur noch vorher gesagt, und das muss ich sozusagen auch unterschreiben, dass es sein kann, dass eben dieser Austausch dazu führt, dass es unter Umständen danach überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert. Und damit müsste ich sozusagen dann leben. Ich müsste dann allerdings auch nichts dafür bezahlen. Also es ist nicht so, dass ich irgendwie 200 Euro zahle und dann hab ich vielleicht ein Telefon, was funktioniert oder nicht. Sondern es kann halt nur sein, dass es nicht funktioniert, aber dann muss ich auch nicht bezahlen. Aber er würde mir halt nicht garantieren können, dass es danach funktioniert.
Das ist ja wirklich so eine Art schon fast Freundschaftsdienst, weil es hat ja dann mit Garantie oder sonst irgendwie nun mit dem Verkauf von Ersatzteilen nichts mehr zu tun. Sondern der macht es für dich.
Na ja, ich bin über 200 Euro. Ich mein, das ist ja ein stolzer Preis irgendwie für so ein...
Ach so, den hättest du bezahlen müssen.
Ja, den hab ich dann auch bezahlt. Ich hab halt gesagt, mach ich. Er hat mir nur gesagt, dass es eben theoretisch, das ist einfach Disclaimer-Politik. Also er musste mich darauf hinweisen und da ich ja eigentlich keine Garantieansprüche habe, also wäre ich jetzt ein T-Mobile-Kunde gewesen, dann ein gesimploktes Telefon da hingetragen, dann hätte er gesagt, naja, im Zweifelsfall gebe ich dir halt einfach ein neues. Aber in meinem Fall war es nur das Angebot, ich tausche das Glas, aber es kann halt sein, was weiß ich, wenn da innen irgendwie alles, was weiß ich wie ist und dann ist irgendwas verbogen, dass es da nicht macht. Na ja, dann hat er das Telefon mitgenommen, weil ich habe gesagt, okay, mach mal. Ich glaub, das wird funktionieren und so. Er ist da hinten in sein Karbeuschen gegangen, 10 Minuten später wieder zurückgekommen und siehe da, auf einmal habe ich ein niegelnagelneues iPhone-Glas gehabt. So, jetzt habe ich ein schönes Kratzerfreies. Für 200 Euro.
Aber hättest du es nicht auch irgendwie für 200 Euro? Da kannst du ja nach Italien fliegen und zurück und...
Ja, was?
Ob wir das dann auf Garantie machen?
Aber da wäre es auch, der Sprung des Glases ist in keinem Fall ein Garantiefall.
Ach so, naja, stimmt auch wieder.
Also das ist auch mit einem deutschen iPhone.
Ich hätte da bestimmt auch in Italien Geld für zahlen müssen. Insofern wäre mir das lieber, das in Hamburg zu machen, als erst mal nach Mailand zu fliegen.
Ich kenne jemanden, der das selber gemacht hat. Bei Ebay kosten Display, ich glaube der Stream ist übrigens weg, Display und Digitizer-Einheit um die 40 Euro. Dafür kriegt man die.
Man braucht noch so einen Saugknopf, um es abzuziehen.
Man braucht eine ganze Menge. Man muss auch mit einem Föhn den Kleister anlösen, weil das so verklebt ist. Das ist etwas, was man auf keinen Fall selber machen sollte, wenn man davon keine Ahnung hat. Wenn man sich zu feinen Mechaniken auskennt, dann kriegt man das durchaus hin.
Ich habe hier schon so ein 3G auseinandergenommen mit einem Kumpel, die zwei Schrauben unten, mit einem Saugknopf das Display nach oben abziehen. Aber nur ganz minimal, weil darunter sind drei Flachbandkabel für lauter Zeugs. Die darf man nicht abreißen, sondern die muss man vorsichtig rausziehen. Das ist alles nicht so das Problem. Das Problem ist eher nachher, weil die so kurz und die Flachbandkabel, das beim Zusammenstecken musst du fast mit wenig Platz, weil das Display muss da schon wieder drüber hängen, diese Flachbandkabel wieder reinkriegen. Ich glaube, das war das größte Problem an der ganzen Sache. Da wäre so eine Pinzette gut, die so ein bisschen gummiert ist vorne, damit sie die Flachbandkabel nicht kaputt kratzt. Aber sonst war das eigentlich alles easy.
Du musst mal dein Mikrofon ein bisschen höher machen, weil so unter unten, genau.
Machst du den Darth Vader?
Machst du den Darth Vader 2.0.
So, weiter. App Store.
Apple Phone. Am Ende, ich hatte einen 15-Minuten-Slot, am Ende hat, glaube ich, die Gesamtbetreuung über 20 Minuten gedauert. So, keinem Zeitpunkt wurde in irgendeiner Form auf mich so ein Tumor.
Eingeredet?
Ja, also es kam nie irgendwelche Hektik auf. Und es war einfach extrem angenehm, muss ich sagen. Und am Ende hatte ich halt dieses Telefon.
Du hast dir ein Telefon in Italien gekauft, dass es hier nur keine Straftat hat.
Vor allem, die haben 200 Euro verdient.
Ja, sie haben 200 Euro daran verdient.
Ja, na gut, aber sie haben da Termine. Und die vergeben sie irgendwie in 15 Minuten Abstand. Ich hab jetzt keine Ahnung, wie die Termine lagen. Ich sag ja nur, es war einfach nicht so, dass ich mich in irgendeiner Form da gepusht fühlte. Ich fand das sehr angenehm. Dann wollte ich noch einen Zubehörteil kaufen, das hatten sie leider nicht. Dann hab ich noch so ein bisschen rumgesurft. Ach so, jetzt so ein iPod-Anschlusskabel fürs Auto. Aber das gab es da irgendwie nicht.
Oh, was war das denn gerade?
Das war ich den falschen... Jetzt hab ich auf jeden Fall ein iPhone 3G, was irgendwie tadellos funktioniert ist. Auf der Rückseite ein bisschen zerkratzt, vorne überhaupt nicht. Nee, das ist mein neues, das hab ich jetzt nicht hier. Aber das sieht jetzt sozusagen von vorne total nagelneu aus und ist irgendwie frisch gereinigt und er meint, er hätte auch aus dem Gerät noch eine größere Teilmenge Dreck herausgeblasen. Das wäre also wohl ganz ordentlich versüfft gewesen drin. Und...
War ja auch schon eineinhalb Jahre alt.
Und wie lange hat er das Display ausgewechselt?
Zehn Minuten weniger.
Zehn Minuten, das ist aber echt...
Na ja, die zwei Schrauben, Saugnopf hochgehoben, die drei Steckkabel abgetauscht. Er hat dann das andere gleich da irgendwie, packt es wieder drauf und macht die drei Flachbandkabel da wieder rein und fertig. Und ich meine, wenn er das öfter mal macht, dann kann er das ja auch ganz schnell.
Und sauber gemacht hat.
Ich bin trotzdem beeindruckt.
Also, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das irgendwie...
Also, ich habe jetzt nicht so direkt auf die Uhr geguckt, ob es wirklich zehn Minuten war. Es kann sogar nur fünf Minuten gewesen sein. Auf jeden Fall dauerte es nicht lange.
Also, du musstest das Gerät nicht dalassen oder irgendwie so was?
Überhaupt nicht. Also, letzten Endes habe ich die Experience gehabt. Ich bin dahin gefahren, wurde irgendwie freundlich behandelt, habe dann irgendwie eine Apple-typische Strafbezahlung bezahlt, aber habe dafür auch bekommen, was ich wollte. So, und jetzt ist das Telefon halt sozusagen wieder funktionsfähig. Ich brauche es derzeit halt nicht. Jetzt überlege ich, was ich damit mache, ob ich es jetzt verkaufe oder nicht.
Nein.
Also, die totale Apple Experience. Alles war super und du hast viel Geld verloren.
Ja, so kann man das festhalten. Alles war super und ich habe dafür auch ordentlich bezahlen dürfen.
Ich habe auf meinem 3GS endlich mal einen Jailbreak gemacht. Jetzt, wenn es einen für 3, 2, irgendwas gibt. Was ist die aktuelle Firma? 312. Bisher habe ich noch keinen Unlock gemacht. Jetzt ist natürlich die dänliche Frage, wofür brauche ich überhaupt einen Unlock? Ich habe ja einen in Vertragsfreies. Den Unlock braucht man. Mit einem Unlock kriegt man dann wieder Tessering hin.
Irgendeiner hat hier noch irgendwie Funk an.
Also ich habe Funk an, aber... Und das ist... Ja, also mit Tessering geht jetzt... Also mit einem Unlock könnte ich dann wieder Tessering nutzen. Mit dem Augenblick noch nicht. Was ich allerdings für ein App ganz süß finde, ist Orbit heißt das, kostet 1,99 Dollar. Und damit kann man hier so im Dashboard, wenn man hier so drauf ist, tippt man drauf, dann sieht man so einen Übersichtsbildschirm über alle seine Screens, die man so hat. Das dauert beim ersten Mal ein bisschen länger. Dann kann man direkt auf das Screen springen.
Exposé fürs iPhone.
Quasi so ein bisschen exposé fürs iPhone.
Aber dafür brauchst du kein jailbroken Phone, oder?
Doch, dafür braucht man ein jailbroken Phone. Echt? Ich glaube, es gibt keine Möglichkeit für Apps.
Aber sie kostet Geld?
Ja.
Es gibt da...
Du kannst Apps kaufen...
Du kannst im Zydiastore... Das ist ein richtiger Store.
Das sind die Leute, die für Vers bezahlen.
Das ist...
Die Diskussion hatten wir auch schon mal. Hacker-Mentalität, ne? Wenn irgendwie gehackt, dann auch kostenlos. Aber...
Also ich find's... Und der gleiche Mensch, der das, dieses Orbit da geschrieben hat, der sitzt jetzt wohl noch an einer anderen Lösung, und zwar dann an einer Multitasking-Lösung fürs iPhone.
Was hast du jetzt gemacht? Du hast jetzt aktuelle Firmware aufgespielt, ein Jailbreak dafür gemacht und hast jetzt dein Tethering wieder einschalten können, oder was?
Nee, Tethering, ich hab jetzt noch keinen Unlock gemacht. Mit anderen Worten, Tethering hab ich auch nach wie vor noch nicht. Ich hab jetzt erst mal Tethering...
Was heißt denn bitte jetzt ein Unlock bei einem Unlocked Phone?
Und offensichtlich steckt diese Information, welches Profile er akzeptiert. Also auf jeden Fall, wenn man den Unlock macht, auch auf dem hier, also wenn man diesen Perp, wie heißt der, Black Rain von Geohot diesen Unlock macht, dann kann man danach auch wieder Tethering machen, auch wenn man vorher schon ein geunlocktes Telefon hatte. Also der macht dann alles auf einen Schlag, der macht den SIM-Unlock, den ich nicht bräuchte, und er macht gleichzeitig noch das Tethering, wie der geht, und weiß etwa, was alles macht, gleich mit. Und dann hat man, und die Erfahrung war übrigens relativ großartig. Also ich hab mir diesen Black Rain runtergeladen.
Also dieser Unlock führt ja sozusagen dazu, dass man auch diese signierten Profile nicht braucht.
Das ist dann der Unlock. Aber der Jailbreak, der war wirklich bisher die beste Jailbreak-Erfahrung, die ich so hatte. Anschließen, Programm starten, Button klicken, 20 Sekunden warten ungefähr, Telefon startet neu, ist gejailbreakt, und dann hast du ein kleines Icon, mit dem du zusätzlich zu dir oder Rock nachinstallieren kannst.
Erstaunlich, dass die das immer noch so einfach hinkriegen.
Na, Apple sucht jetzt auch gerade einen neuen Sicherheitsspezial für die iPhone-Abteilung.
Ah, war es dann doch ein bisschen...
Also entweder hatten sie vorher keinen, oder er wurde gestieft.
Ach so, hat die mal im Fahrstuhl getroffen, oder was?
Na, ich meine, geht ja gar nicht.
Ja gut, besonders erfolgreich scheinen sie ja nicht gewesen zu sein, hat mich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen überrascht.
Na ja, wir haben ja alle hier so das Glück der Frühgeboten hier, und zwar bei den neuen iPhones ist ja dieses neue Boot, der neue Bootloader drauf. Und bei dem kann man nicht mehr so einfach jailbreaken, da musst du nach jedem Neustart den jailbreak wiederholen.
Nee, den jailbreak?
Na ja, du kannst den Unlock nicht wiederholen. Also, den nennst du tesebring jailbreak, weil du es immer wieder anschließen musst, um irgendwie ein Programm auszuführen. Weil der Bootloader wohl irgendwas verhindert.
Ich bilde mir ein, dass das jetzt mit Black Rain also mit der aktuellen Version auch gelöst ist, das Problem.
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Das wäre nochmal eine interessante Frage.
Das heißt, die haben das schon dem Bootloader mäßig wieder einen Bug gefixt?
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich glaube, es gibt zwei unabhängige Lösungen. Zuerst hat er diesen Jailbreak rausgebracht. Geohot, also Black Rain. Und dann hat er... Das war genau dieser Zustand, den du beschrieben hast. Und jetzt vor ein paar Tagen ist noch...
Das war doch aber nur der Unlock, nicht der Jailbreak.
Jetzt ist nochmal der Unlock gekommen. Aber ich glaube, der hat dann bei der Gelegenheit auch... Also wenn das... Wenn dann anlocken kann, das Bassband, dann kann das doch auch... Aber ich weiß es nicht. Mal gucken, welcher Teil davon jetzt betroffen ist.
Na vielleicht stellt halt der Booter den Originalzustand wieder her und checkt da irgendwas. Deswegen müssen wir das immer wieder machen nach dem Booten. Irgendwie so.
Na das heißt ja, wahrscheinlich haben sie es eh nur im RAM drinne und können es noch nicht auf Platte schreiben.
Ist ja auch so jetzt mit diesem... Das ist ja dieser neue Unlock, beruht ja auf irgendeine Injection. Die Menschen haben ja den nicht umgebaut, sondern sie machen ja irgendwie Code-Injection oder Parameter-Injection, was auch immer. Und vorher haben sie den Code vom Baseband ja geändert, weil sie ja auch schon von den ganz, ganz alten Telefonen, weil sie ja auch den Bootloader da schon gehackt hatten. Deswegen konnte man ja dann anderen aufspielen. Deswegen sind da die ersten Phones auch sozusagen für die Ewigkeit gehackt, weil sie einfach ihren eigenen Bootloader rausgebracht haben. Das geht halt bei den neuen nicht mehr.
Die ganz allerersten iPhone.
Meinst du, dass Giffey das jetzt so in den Griff bekommen hat, mit dem Teil irgendwie? Ich meine, immerhin geht es ja immer noch mit dem Schafen.
Du musst halt mit dem neuen Bootloader immer wieder anschließen. Das ist schon ein bisschen nervig. Stell dir vor, dir geht mal kurz dein iPhone aus. Das ist ja schon ganz selten. Obwohl, eigentlich ist mir schon ewig nicht mehr vorgekommen. Na ja, aber es kann passieren, dass es irgendwie mal ausgeht. Batterie leer, was auch immer. Dann machst du es wieder an, weil du es geladen hast. Und dann müsstest du es erst mal wieder an dein Rechner anschließen, damit es dann geht. Weil die Leute, die den Unlock brauchen, die können ja erst mal nicht mehr telefonieren, wenn das Telefon einmal aus ist, weil sie erst mal wieder anlocken müssen. Das ist schon so ein bisschen blöd. Das heißt, du müsstest auch, wenn du in den Urlaub fährst, nicht nur das Netzteil mitnehmen, sondern auf jeden Fall auch einen Rechner, der es dann wieder anlocken könnte.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, kommt leider auch nicht zu meinem Chat, aber ich bin mir, ich bildete mir ein, dass das Problem jetzt mit dem neuen Unlock dann...
Ich meine, deswegen habe ich mir einen Unlock das gekauft, weil ich auf diesen ganzen Rotz keinen Bock mehr hatte.
Ja, es ist jetzt keine perfekte Lösung und so. Also klar, aber man kann eigene Software drauflaufen lassen, das ist schon besser.
Aber das hier mit dem kaputten Scheibe im deutschen Store ist da schon mal eine Sache, dass du wenigstens viel Geld einem Sachen reparieren hast, ist da schon mal was. Na ja, immerhin musst du nicht für 200 Euro auch noch nach Italien fahren, um es dir da machen zu lassen, für fünf Minuten. Jetzt machen wir ja erst mal hier dieses neue Gadget.
Genau, Hoke hat das neue Gadget damit gebracht. Ich hab die ganze Zeit mich schon damit beschäftigt und ich hab als einziger Vorarbeit geleistet und ein neues Gadget zum Bestaunen auch mitgebracht.
Hervorragend.
Ich hatte ja eigentlich fest damit gerechnet, dass ja alle schon mit diesem Gerät...
Ich versuche gerade Apple-Hardware zu kaufen, aber es ist alles noch nicht lieferbar.
Also bei mir war es so, dass einfach jemand, als dieses Gerät, die Magic Mouse, angekündigt wurde, schon direkt vier Stück geordert hatte und eins mehr, als er dachte, dass er braucht. Also er hat schon zwei Kollegen und so. Dann kam gestern die Mail auf der Mitarbeiterliste, wer denn noch eine Magic Mouse will, ich gleich, bang, Reply, hier, hier, hier, geschrien. Ich kam mal runter, hat erstmal mich ein bisschen rumscrollen lassen, ein bisschen rumklicken lassen und habe mich doch direkt zum Kauf entschlossen. Und seitdem, also selten, habe ich so viel eine Maus gestreichelt.
Erstmal kurz, die Verpackung, die ist ja so ein bisschen lustig bei dem Ding.
Der Schnee-Wildchen-Sarg.
Da war ich total enttäuscht, ehrlich gesagt. Weil erstens ist es ja entgegen ihrer Green-Philosophie total der Plastikbomber. Also ist halt Plastik so. Dann ist das auch nicht wieder verschließbar richtig. Der ist halt zusammengeklebt, so zweiteiliger Plastik, durchsichtiger Sarg. Wenn du die Aufkleber an den Seiten aufmachst und den abnimmst, kriegst du ihn auch nicht mehr so zusammen, dass du deine Maus damit transportieren kannst. Weil natürlich, jetzt will ich nicht nach einer iPhone-Socke auch noch eine Maussocke haben, damit die nicht zerkratzt, die gute Touch-Bohrfläche. Ja, weiß nicht.
Gibt's bestimmt schon.
Ja, gibt's bestimmt.
Maussocken, ich seh grad die Chinesen irgendwie die Maschinen anwerfen jetzt.
Scheiße! Nee, aber das fand ich schon ein bisschen blöd, aber dann hast du halt einfach in der Hand gehabt, eingeschaltet und ging auch sofort los. Dann muss man halt, da es ja 10.6.2. noch nicht gibt, muss man halt einmal perren, dann Software-Update klicken, dann holt er sich dieses Magic Mouse Software-Update runter. Dann muss man Rebooten dafür. Für so eine Maus. Reboot für die Maus. Reboot für die Maus fand ich auch erstmal so ein bisschen shocking. Aber danach geht's dann halt einfach so, wie man sich das vorstellt. Und ja, also sie hatten einen physikalischen Klick für alle, die sich das gefragt haben. Und der ist auch sehr kräftig.
Der Biker-Klick.
Und ich fand, also ich komm mal erst zum Negativen. Ich fand das Control-Panel dazu auch ein bisschen beschränkt. Also man kann gar nicht so viel gesten oder so konfigurieren. Man kann eigentlich nur sagen, ich will einen Rechtsklick. Man kann Geschwindigkeiten einklicken, einstellen. Und dann war es das auch schon. Also ich dachte zum Beispiel, dass bei einer Multitouch-Maus auch einfach ein Tap-Click geht, wie auf einem Touchpad. Also ohne physischen Klicks, sondern einfach nur rauftappen. Sowas geht auch nicht. Pinch-Zoom geht halt auch nicht. Also wenn man halt so reinzoomen will in Preview oder sonst was, gibt es halt auch nicht so, dass man einfach hier so mit den zwei Fingern so drüber pincht. Also ich meine, das sind so Sachen, da könnten sie natürlich mit dem Software-Update noch locker nachlegen, aber okay. Aber eigentlich ist das auch komplett ohne diese ganzen Features total toll. Also ich hab selten so gerne mit einer Maus gescrollt wie mit dieser. Man hat halt die ganze, also man muss es mal gefühlt haben.
Das ist so dieses kinetische Scrolling, ne? Das du das so ein bisschen weiterscrollst, auch von alleine, wenn du...
Genau, das ist aber ein Snow Leopard-Feature, dieses beschleunigte Scrolling.
Warum geht das auf meinem Trackpad nicht?
Aber es ist immer noch so im Gegensatz zum iPhone, du kannst nicht drüber hinausscrollen und dann springt er so wieder zurück. Das geht nicht, oder?
Darüber hinausscrollen?
Das ist so, dass er ins schwarze, ins Space kommt, sozusagen, und der dann zurückspringt ein bisschen. Das finde ich ja extrem cool, das Feature.
Also bei der Mighty Mouse kann man auf jeden Fall so den Scroll anstupsen und es läuft dann auf Snow Leopard, es scrollt sozusagen ein bisschen nach. Man nennt das Easing, glaube ich, dann.
Ja, Ease in und Ease out.
Aber das ist ganz geil, dass wenn man dann den Finger kurz wieder drauf legt, dass man es dann sofort wieder stoppen kann. Also eigentlich genauso wie beim iPhone, genauso wie man es erwartet würde.
Und es klingt total trivial, aber alle, die jetzt schon diese Mouse in der Hand hatten von mir, die hier waren auch so...
Das waren aber in erster Linie Leute wie wir, oder?
Ja, weiß nicht so, aber halt normale Kollegen, die jetzt nicht unbedingt so diesen Gadget-Heaper haben oder total Apple-versessen sind, auch wenn sie ein Apple-Gerät haben, das kam auf jeden Fall gut an. Und ich bin da auch total begeistert von. Und sie hat einen farblosen Laser. Ich glaube, es gibt ja Infrarotlasermäuse, oder? Jungs, hier, nicht schlafen.
Ja, ja.
Also ich glaube, Infrarotlaser ist ja schon auch durchaus verbreitet bei diversen Maus-Herstellern.
Und die ist auch so, ja.
Also man sieht den Laser halt nicht.
Wie ist denn das internationale Podcast?
Funktioniert das Ding hier auf diesem weißen, glatten Tisch?
Funktioniert super, ja.
Das ist doch wie bei dieser coolen Maus, die auf einer Glasscheibe funktioniert?
Ich hab hier nämlich noch die alte Maus und die funktioniert überhaupt nicht auf diesem Tisch.
Und auch die Mighty Maus, die hat auch nicht funktioniert.
Was ist auf die Mighty Maus hier, oder?
Aber meine hat nicht rot geleuchtet, glaube ich. Also ich hab eine Mighty Maus ohne Kabel gehabt.
Die mit Bluetooth. Die hat dann blau geleuchtet, oder was?
Ich weiß gar nicht, hat die rot geleuchtet. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Die Technologie ist dann dieselbe, aber die Maus funktioniert auf diesem Tisch hier einfach überhaupt nicht. Deswegen hab ich hier auch irgendwie so einen Unterleger. Also die nimmt hier keinerlei Bewegung wahr. Und die funktioniert.
Die funktioniert auch bisher auf allen Tischen, wo sonst meine alte Microsoft-Maus auch nicht funktioniert hat.
Aber ist das denn eine andere Technologie, die da unten zum Einsatz kommt?
Also das sieht ja sehr nach Infrarot aus.
Man sieht da so einen ganz leichten Schimmer auf meinem Finger, wenn ich den so da drüber halte.
Also mir hat jemand gesagt, das wäre ein Infrarotlaser.
Naja, ist. Hier kann ich mit dem iPhone das Ding aufnehmen, weil der zeigt das ja sichtbar an. Dann sieht man da so einen ganz leichten blauen Schimmer auf meinem Finger.
Steht denn da auf der Maus drauf, dass da Laser drin ist? Weil ich glaube, wo Laser drin ist, muss auch Laser draufstehen.
Naja, der ist so schwach wahrscheinlich.
Auf der Maus steht das nicht, ne?
Nein, kein irgendwie Warning.
Dann hat man gewissen Stärke, oder?
Tim, wie ist denn das internationale Podcast-Handzeichen für Internet-Tot? Damit das jetzt nicht so auffällt, hier mit einem Podcast, dass das Internet weg ist.
Stimmt, ich kann jetzt auch gar nicht nachgucken.
Das Internet ist tot.
Das Internet ist tot. Ich hole mal mein Taschen-Internet raus.
Wollen wir nicht einfach die Sendung weitermachen?
Ah, jetzt kommt's.
Natürlich machen wir die Sendung einfach weiter. Wir haben gar keine andere Wahl. Letzten Endes ist das immer noch ein Podcast.
Ja, aber da ist das Netz wieder.
Wie findest du denn diese Gesten da, mit dem Swipe und so? Ist das ein bisschen anstrengend, mit zwei Fingern links, rechts?
Ja, aber das brauch ich auch ehrlich gesagt kaum. Ich brauchte jetzt eigentlich nur meine neue Maus und ich dachte mal, ich probier's mal wieder mit der Apple-Maus.
Aber so scrollen, 360 Grad mit einem Finger?
Das ist super. Das ist genau so, wie man das haben will. Das ist wirklich extrem toll, ohne Scroll-Wheel und so einfach da rüber zu wischen.
Hast du einen zweiten Maus-Button irgendwie konfiguriert?
Echt?
Du benutzt das auch? Das ist aber genauso wie vorher, dass man da diesen einen Finger hochheben muss und so? Also von Gewohnheit, ich hab das hier mal testweise gestern nochmal wieder eingeschaltet, das war irgendwie nach 20 Minuten wieder ausgeschaltet.
Ich komm damit super klar, aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch benutzerabhängig.
Der Nazi-Button, also ich weiß nicht.
Also auf jeden Fall muss ich sagen, das ist von den Apple-Mäusen, die es in den letzten Jahren so rausgebracht haben, die erste, die ich ernsthaft wieder benutzen kann. Also ich fand zum Beispiel die Mighty Mouse, ich komm mit diesen Namen jetzt schon durcheinander, aber das ist die Mighty. Das ist die Mighty Mouse, mit dem Ball. Die fand ich zum Beispiel halt auch...
Mighty Board.
Naja, also ich bin Freund dem...
Bei Mäusen und Tastaturen, da wirst du niemals eine hellige Meinung kriegen. Ich meine, ich will immer nach wie vor noch das selbe haben. Ich hab's schon 1000 mal gesagt. Ich hätte gerne einfach eine Tastatur mit einem Trackpad, genauso wie das auf dem Laptop auch ist. Quasi einfach nur das Oberteil rausgeschält und dann... Hätte man sozusagen alles...
Im Couch surfen.
Also was ich jetzt gerne hätte, wäre...
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz zeigen. Das hat mir nämlich ein Hörer zugeschickt. Das könnt ihr natürlich jetzt im Podcast nicht sehen, aber ich werde es euch gleich beschreiben. Jetzt erstmal die unmittelbare Reaktion.
Ja, aber es muss unten drunter sein.
Das ist jetzt so eine gefotoshoppte Wireless-Tastatur, wo dann das Trackpad so rechts daneben geklebt ist. Also wo sonst vielleicht ein Numpad ist. Aber schön gemacht so mit Werbung. Jetzt kommt zusammen, was zusammen gehört irgendwie.
Also ich finde dieses Produkt tatsächlich auch kaufenswert. Würde ich mir shoppen.
Die Tastatur.
Tastatur mit Trackpad, weil dann kannst du halt den Rechner irgendwie mit Beamer sonst wohin und chillst dich auf Sofa und kannst einfach musst hier nicht mit so einer Maus rumhantieren.
Ja, aber vor allem wenn du nur auf dem Stuhl sitzt und eigentlich gar keine horizontale Fläche hast.
Ja, aber dann müsste eigentlich die Tastatur sollte das auch so aussehen wie bei einem normalen Laptop, dass du das Trackpad unterhalb der Tastatur hast.
Ja, natürlich kann.
Das finde ich viel, viel besser.
Damit man die Hände auch so drauf anzuhalten.
Aber ich finde, was ich jetzt gerne hätte wäre für mein MacBook, das Kinetisch.
Es gibt übrigens ein solches Produkt. Kann ich euch auch nochmal zeigen.
Es gibt diesen EEPC, ne?
Was? Nein, nein, ich rede jetzt wirklich von so einer Funktassatur. Das sieht furchtbar aus, ich weiß. Und es hat auch zwei Maustasten.
Da haben sie irgendwie das Display von... Sieht aus wie so ein Kompakt-PC von 1996.
Na wie auch immer, ist von Key Sonic. Mit dem blumigen Namen ACK540.
Kaufen.
Mac. Und ist auch nicht Bluetooth, sondern ist irgendwie so Funk über USB-Stick und so.
Tolle.
Aber ich find's auch nicht so interessant. Ich meine, preislich ist interessant, kostet irgendwie 64 Euro. Löst dann unter Umständen mal auch ein Problem. Also für so ein, was weiß ich so, Mediencenter, Fernbedienungseinheit oder Computer an Fernseher angeschlossen, Dingsbums, ist es dann halt schon eine Lösung.
Aber das Apple Trackpad ist umso vieles besser wegen 2-Finger-Scrollen, 3-Finger-Gesten.
Das weiß ich alles, aber es gibt dieses Produkt nicht. Apple will es mir nicht bauen.
Was es gibt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das erkennen könnt, ich glaube mittlerweile ist sogar verfügbar von Asus das IEE-Keyboard.
Das ist ein Keyboard, wo rechts ein Computer mit eingebaut ist.
Nee, da ist komplett der Computer mit eingebaut. Das ist einfach nur ein Keyboard, so wie der C64.
Ach, echt? C64, quasi. Aber der Bildschirm ist auch eingebaut.
Mit schicker Alutastatur. Nee, das ist ein zusätzlicher Bildschirm.
Das ist sozusagen ein Tablet mit Tastatur dran, ja.
Nee, das ist...
Was ist das denn für die Zehner-Tastatur, die man dann so ins Topf...
Na, das ist dann quasi, das ist das Trackpad, also ein Glas-Trackpad. Und du kannst das entweder per Kabel oder per Funk-HDMI...
Ach so, das ist auch ein Trackpad rechts neben der Tastatur.
Genau, das ist ein Trackpad rechts neben der Tastatur, das aber noch ein Display eingebaut hat. Zum Beispiel gedacht für, wenn du das an ein Fernseher anschließt, dann willst du ja nicht unbedingt die ganzen Kontrollelemente auf dem Fernseher haben, sondern dann hast du ja noch so ein kleines On-Screen-Display dran. Ich hab's auf der CeBit mir mal angeguckt, macht einen sehr, sehr wertigen Eindruck, allerdings hab ich es ja nicht in Aktionen gesehen. Und ich weiß nicht, was der Scheiß kostet und mit dem Funk und weiß ja toll was. Also ich bin nicht... Aber es ist...
Was es alles so gibt.
Gibt es das mittlerweile eigentlich mal?
Das ist so verrückt. So, jetzt guck ich mal in die Wave. Ich bin ja ganz froh, dass die Leute...
Ich hab ja noch die zwei Joker-Themen, ne?
Du hast auch noch die Joker-Themen.
Ja, Joker-Themen, da kommen wir gleich noch drauf. Ich schau nur grad mal, was hier so steht. Ich bin ja sehr dankbar für diese Beiträge hier in der Wave. Und das zeigt auch mal, wie Google Wave, ich hoffe, dass diesmal jetzt schon mehr einen Account haben. Nicht, dass sich jetzt wieder so viele ausgeschlossen fühlen. Aber wir haben jetzt hier insgesamt, was weiß ich, wie viele Leute tragen hier zu bei? Das steht natürlich hier nicht. Ich zähle ungefähr so 30 Leute, die hier dran mitschreiben. Und da sind halt viele interessante Hinweise auf mögliche Themen. Wir werden natürlich jetzt hier nicht über alles reden. Allein schon deshalb, weil ich für bestimmte Sachen auch einfach nicht so erwähnenswert finde. Also jetzt diese blöden Gerüchte, die da aufkommen, mit irgendwie, ja, jetzt läuft irgendein Beta-Bild nicht mehr auf dem Atomprozessor. Und das nächste läuft dann wieder. Ich meine, da kann man echt sinnlos Zeit mitfragen. Aber eine Meldung ist natürlich zwischendurch noch interessant. Das iPhone wird ja jetzt auch in China verkauft.
Ja, davon hat man auch nicht viel gehört.
Und soweit ich das mitbekomme, wirst du den AAC, der dir diese Meldung interessant findet, inklusive den Chinesen?
Ach so, weil es nicht so richtig läuft.
Weil es nicht so richtig gut läuft.
Na gut, ich meine, das sind jetzt so Berichte, das muss nicht der Wahrheit entsprechen. Andererseits ist es natürlich schon so, dass das Telefon ohne WLAN kommt. Und von daher natürlich mächtig uninteressant ist, wenn man sich das gleiche Scheiß auch in Hongkong für denselben Preis kaufen kann, ohne diese Einschränkung.
Wie ist denn das eigentlich? War da nicht noch mehr so Einschränkungen drinne im Sinne von China Telecom, oder ist das jetzt wieder raus, dass die auf keinen Fall einen App-Store haben wollten?
Also es ist China Unicom, muss man mal so sagen. Das ist ja der einzige UMTS-Provider.
China Unicom, okay.
China Unicom. China Telecom ist sozusagen...
Ist das WLAN die einzige Einschränkung, die man hat in dem Ding?
Soweit ich das weiß, ja.
Weil ich glaube, da war noch zwischendurch noch mal ein Haufen anderer dämlicher Einschränkungen drin, wie zum Beispiel so, er schmeißt diesen App Store raus. Das ist ja ganz furchtbar. Das will ja keiner im Telefon haben. Ich weiß es aber nicht mehr, ob es genau das war.
Also habe ich jetzt weder was von gehört, noch ist das so, noch halte ich das für wahrscheinlich. Also das ist dann wirklich Quatsch. Es ist die Frage, ob die Chinesen da auf irgendwelche Apps auch noch Einfluss haben wollen, so wie bei Google, wenn dann irgendwie die ersten Fallung Gong-Applikationen zum Download angeboten werden. Weißt du, so Fallung Gong-News irgendwie über verschlüsselt auf deinem iPhone, könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass das nicht so richtig durchkommt. Also das wird dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht erst, naja gut. Na, wenn die das jetzt in den US-App Store... Interessanter Punkt, oder? Ich meine...
Die Zensurbehörde?
Ja, die Zensurbehörde. Ich meine, das eingebaute Zensur so leicht, kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass im chinesischen App Store irgendwie so ein Kram rauskommt.
Na ja, wahrscheinlich sind die Seiten eh komplett gesperrt und dann kannst du so auf dem iPhone genau...
Du musst ja nicht über HTTP und Tralala machen, sondern du kannst ja da über irgendwelche obskuren, betorrend oder sonstigen Sachen, die die Daten auf das Telefon holen. Also das ließe sich ja schon machen. Vor allem, wenn du die volle Power einer Applikation hast, die ja da sehr intelligent irgendwie durchs Netz skreppen kann und hier und da und du so mal gucken können. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich jemanden releasen wird, so eine Software und ich glaube auch nicht, dass Apple die dann in den Store packen würde.
Dann soll das iPhone in China sagenhaft teuer sein, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Das kostet glaube ich...
Irgendwie so etwas um die 1000 Dollar mit Vertrag oder irgendwie sowas. Ich habe wirklich irgendwie Zahlen gehört, die...
700 Euro habe ich gehört.
700 Euro, das kommt ja fast hin mit 1000 Dollar.
Ja, das was es auch überall sonst kostet.
Und naja, aber mit Vertrag ist... Und das mit WLAN, das ist aber kein... Das ist nicht Apple oder China Unicom, sondern das ist einfach... Die haben da so Gesetze, die das...
Genau, das hat einfach nicht...
Mau hat gesagt, ein Gerät, das UMTS kann, darf kein WLAN haben.
Na ja, da kann man das halt nicht so gut kontrollieren, was dieses Gerät macht. Damit könnte man ja im Internet surfen und überhaupt frei sein.
Ich nehme an, das wird irgendwelche technischen... Das ist so wie... Das kriegt wahrscheinlich einfach keine technische Zulassung, weil es darf ja nicht sein, was nicht sein kann oder irgendwie sowas. Das wollen sie ja auch demnächst ändern, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Ist schon ein bisschen absurd. Ich hab mich da auch sehr gewundert, dass sie das mitmachen.
Das ist eigentlich lustig, dass wahrscheinlich die meisten Geräte mit UMTS und WLAN drin überhaupt produziert werden.
Aber sie machen halt nach wie vor nur ein iPhone. Ich halte auch von diesen Gerüchten, dass sie jetzt für Verizon in den USA ein iPhone rausbringen, was auch noch CDMA-Support hat. Da glaub ich so recht nicht dran.
Dass das auch noch hat? Dass ein iPhone beide Radios drin hat?
Ja, das glaub ich einfach nicht.
Das glaubst du nicht?
Nee, das glaub ich nicht.
Gibt's denn aktuelle Chips, die das noch so machen? Wird's schon noch geben, ne Weile, oder?
Es gibt wohl da jetzt so einen Chip, der sowas hat, um eben genau diese Migration da zu machen, weil Verizon muss ja kurz oder lang von diesem CDMA-Kram auch weg. Das hat ja alles keine Zukunft.
Wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Ich hab neulich gehört, dass die keine SIM-Karte haben.
Ähm, bei CDMA?
Also ich hab das daran gehört, dass jemand... Guck mal, hier ist ein Bild von dem Motorola Droid mit einem SIM-Kart-Slot. Und dann wussten alle sofort, was das bedeutet. Und ich dachte mir so, hm, SIM-Kart-Slot, das ist ja nicht immer, das ist ja ein Telefon. Und dann, ne, das ist nur bei GSM-Telefonen, dass die ein SIM-Kart-Slot haben. Bei CDMA-Telefonen muss das irgendwie anders gelöst sein. Weiß ja nix nicht, wie. Wäre mal eine interessante Frage, finde ich.
Na, das, ja, vielleicht haben die die Geräte einfach irgendeine ID und darüber läuft das dann.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Gute Frage, habe ich mir noch nie Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Vielleicht in der Deletopedia.
Oh, nicht die Diskussion, bitte. Okay, jetzt zieh doch mal deinen ersten Hasen da aus dem...
Ja, jetzt wollen wir mal sehen.
Mal sehen, ob das... Also, letzte Woche habe ich ja erzählt, dass es diesen... Zettel wäre es genau. Dass es demnächst eine neue Neta-Talk-Version gibt. Also, es ist das Reihe Source-Tool, was irgendwie dieses Apple-File-Sharing-Protokoll irgendwie macht, damit man zum Beispiel auf Linux, RBSD, Solaris und so weiter irgendwie sich auch mit einem Mac nicht Samba-connected, sondern mit dem hauseigenen AFP. Und wie gesagt, die aktuelle Version ist 204 und demnächst gibt es eine Version 205. Und nachdem ich vor zwei Wochen nach Hause gekommen bin, hatte ich ja schon kurz erzählt von diesem Tool, dass es ja dann mit Time-Maschinen-Fähigkeiten rauskommt und man es ja mal testen müsste. Dann kam ich nach Hause und dachte mir so, fuck it, das testen wir mal gleich. Habe es irgendwie runtergeladen. 205 Release Candidate 3 gibt es bei SourceForge. Also einfach bei Google eintippen, Netatalk, irgendwie dann landet man da. Dann bei Downloads gibt es den Release Candidate 3, habe ich ausprobiert, installiert auf meinem FreeBSD zu Hause, der sowieso schon Netatalk hatte. Also ich hatte das alles schon installiert und habe ganz normal meinen Share, da wo ich so Zeug ablegen kann. Habe dann sozusagen die 204 rausgeschmissen, habe die 205 RC3 dahingelegt und die haben mir gesagt, sie unterstützen Time-Maschinen. Habe ich gedacht, okay, gucken wir mal ab. Das Ding also gemountet. Habe irgendwie meinem Time-Maschine hier gesagt, alles klar, wo willst du den Backup machen? Habe ich gesagt, okay, auf dieses gemountete Volume von meiner FreeBSD-Kiste.
Das hat er dir auch von sich aus angeboten?
Ich habe nichts gemacht, außer diesen 205 RC3 installiert. Weil da gibt es ja noch diese Tricks, dass du da irgendwie so einen Pfeil setzt, also touchen musst, dass es irgendwie das Support hat. Und die ganzen Tricks von früher, die es alles so gibt, habe ich alles nicht gemacht, sondern einfach gesagt, ok, schieb mal mein Backup da auf dieses gemountete Ding. Hat er zugelassen, habe ich geklickt, hat er gesagt, ok, das Ding ist ja hier gemountet, hat er gesagt, ich müsste dafür jetzt mal mein Passwort eingeben, damit er das dann in Zukunft irgendwie selber mounten könnte, habe ich ihm gegeben, hat er irgendwie losgelegt, Backup gemacht, ok, war er irgendwie fertig, hat eine Stunde gedauert, oder eine halbe, keine Ahnung, ich habe ja so ein paar Megabyte. Und dann dachte ich, ok, das ist jetzt erstmal so noch irgendwie easy, das kann ja jeder. Hab dann ausgeschaltet und habe das auch unmountet, weil vorher musste ich es einmal von Hand mounten, damit das Time-Maschine das her sehen kann. Hab das dann unmountet von Hand und habe dann oben in Time-Maschine gesagt, so jetzt mach mal Backup. Hatte das Ding von Hand selber gemountet, hat irgendwie da nochmal 5 Megabyte rüber geschoben oder so, hat es wieder unmountet und war fertig. Nicht schlecht. Okay, Ethernet rausgezogen, WLAN, genau das Gleiche. Hat funktioniert. Ich dachte, okay, das heißt ja immer alles noch nichts.
Das hat funktioniert.
Dass er das Backup gemacht hat. Er hat von alleine das...
Obwohl du WLAN und Ethernet rausgezogen hast.
Nee, nee, nicht beides. Ich hab das Ethernet rausgezogen, dass er es dann über WLAN machen kann. Ich hab sozusagen meine Konnektivität, meine Art gewechselt, um mal zu gucken, ob das dann auch und so weiter. Weil auf dem Share hat er auch eingetragen, ich glaub die MAC-Adresse von meinem Rechner, damit er erkennt, welcher Rechner wo was wie hinlegt und so weiter. Und dann wollte ich mal gucken, ob es dann auch über die, ist das eine andere MAC-Adresse, ob es dann auch noch weitergeht und er das gleiche Backup nimmt und so weiter. Da dachte ich, okay, ist ja alles noch easy, aber ist ja immer noch nicht so jetzt hier Top Quality. Hab ich gedacht, jetzt booten wir mal, mal sehen, ob er es dann immer noch macht. Hab gebootet, kam mal hoch, musste ich gar nichts machen, hat er gleich von alleine das Ding gefunden, gemountet, Backup gemacht, zack, war fertig. Das heißt, ich hab nur diesen Demon gewechselt und seitdem macht er hier Backup ohne... Also ich muss nichts mehr machen, das rockt einfach.
Aber?
Aber, jetzt kommts.
Du hast Fallvolt an, ne?
Ja, das war aber vorher genauso auch.
Moment, Moment, aber wenn du dich auslogst, Backup, dann trotzdem weiter auf das Network-Volume, okay? Das ist ja extrem cool.
Macht das Ding auch Bonjour oder was jetzt?
Nee, das nicht, aber ich hab einen Kumpel, der auch so eine Freebeast-Tierkiste hat und auch so ein Bastleis, und der hat schon vor über einem Jahr irgendwie nach diesen Anleitungen, die es so gab, sich dieses Time Machine Zeug gebastelt, also dass man da dieses Image selber hinlegt und so. Kann ich gleich noch den Grund erzählen, warum das vorher nicht ging. Und der hat sich auch irgendwie den automatischen Bonjour-Announcer gebastelt, der das sozusagen dem Time Machine gleich beibringt, dass da ein Gerät ist, was es kann, dass man es als Backup aushält. Das heißt, dann müsste man doch nicht mal mehr von Hand mounten und dem Time Machine sagen, mach mal das Backup beim ersten Mal, sondern dann würde es sozusagen schon auch vorher von ganz alleine finden. Aber es ist nur beim ersten Mal so, deswegen hat es mich nicht so interessiert, müsste man aber auch noch machen. Was er mir noch gezeigt hat, ist, dass sein, der hat sich da so ein 6TB-Rate irgendwie gebaut letztens mit irgendwie 5-6 Platten und richtig fett, dass mit dem Bonjour kann man auch noch die Art von seinem Mac irgendwie setzen, also was man denn für ein Produkt hat. Und der hat sich eingetragen, dass er ein Apple-Rate hat, deswegen kommt bei ihm jetzt immer so ein Apple-Rate im Bolle als gemountetes Volumen. Da kann man gleich erkennen, ich bin jetzt auf dem Server, das ist irgendwie dekortiert. Das ist ganz cool. Und das ist auch alles gar nicht so gefuscht und gemacht und getan, also so von hinten, sondern dieses Bonjour, da gibt es ein Apple-Dokument, wo alles genau erklärt ist mit diesen Time-Maschinen, was ist irgendwie, was man machen muss, was ist irgendwie das AfD irgendwie können muss und so weiter und so fort. Also es ist irgendwie sehr wohl dokumentiert.
Seit wann ist das denn so? Das kenne ich noch gar nicht, das Dokument.
Ich habe das letztens auch irgendwie gefunden, weil in dieser Netatalk-Mailingliste, da haben die das irgendwo verlinkt, weil da auch die neuesten Features für AP, also Apple-Falschein-Protokoll 3.2 und ich glaube auch schon 3.3, bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher.
Hast du den Link dann auch irgendwo? Kannst du den mal...
Den müsste ich jetzt erstmal eine Weile fummeln, kann ich aber nach der Sendung nochmal schnell irgendwie zusammen suchen.
Wird mir auch mal interessant.
Der wird auf jeden Fall in einer Netatalk-Mailingliste im letzten Monat irgendwo erwähnt. Und die schreiben da nicht so viel. Nur Sourceforge irgendwie zu klicken, ist echt eine Qual, weil jeder Klick dauert mehrere Sekunden. Das ist echt... Macht eure Projekte bloß weg von Sourceforge, das ist total schlimm. Ja, also was wir an 205 geändert haben, was 204 nicht konnte, ist erstens, dass mit 204 konnte man oder konnte das OS X schon dieses Image auf einem gemounteten Volume nicht anlegen. Das ging einfach nicht. Da hat das Time Machine schon mal abgebrochen, deswegen war da früher der Trick, dass man das halt von Hand erstellt oder sich eins von woanders dann irgendwie dorthin kopiert, dass es schon da ist.
Stand da auch, warum ist das nicht konnte? Also was?
Ich, das weiß ich nicht, ich kann nur eine Sache sagen, die sie gefixt haben, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es auch mit diesem Disc Image zusammenhängt. Und zwar eine Sache ist, dass es jetzt ein Feature gibt, was es Netatalk unterstützt, das heißt irgendwie TM, bla bla, Log-Style. Also sie können den Log auf einen File sich klauen. Wahrscheinlich, wenn einer irgendwie damit... Ja, weiß ich nicht, wofür.
Wenn einer den anderen Datei geloggt hat, das ist dann einfach...
Ja, ich habe letztens nachgedacht, dass es ja für lokal ist, damit halt der immer Backup machen kann, auch wenn gerade ein anderer das File geloggt hat, aber eigentlich geht es ja um das Remote Share, das Feature muss ja dort existieren und da der selber den Backup Zugriff hat. Ich weiß nicht, wofür sie es sich genau haben, aber sie haben auf jeden Fall ein paar Features eingebaut, die wohl nicht so schwer waren, dass es schon in 205 Timing Machine Support anbieten konnten. Eigentlich war es erst für 2.1 geplant, aber sie haben es jetzt schon vorgezogen. Und da kommen noch mehr coole Features, also spätestens dann in 2.1, weil auch da die neue AFP-Version unterstützt wird. Und zwar, dass sie sich so eine Art Replay-Cache machen, dass wenn dein OS, dein Client irgendwie zugreift und ein Kommando abschickt und danach bricht irgendwie die Verbindung zusammen, dein Netz ist weg, was auch immer, dann kann es, wenn die Verbindung danach wieder da ist und dein Rechner wurde nicht gebootet, sondern es war nur ein kurzer Dropout, so wie wir hier das gerade mit unserem Netz so haben, dann kann der fragen, so ging denn hier irgendwie mein letzter Move, ging der irgendwie durch und der Server, der hat sich den gemerkt, entweder er hat ihn ausgeführt, weil er angekommen ist, dann sagt er, ja, habe ich prima gemacht oder nee, habe ich nicht gemacht, dafür mache ich den jetzt. Aber also das heißt, die halten sich so den letzten State, dass sie bei so einer Unterbrechung dann fortführen können. Und das wird wohl für Time Machine auch gebraucht, damit die schneller arbeiten können. Also da kommen demnächst Performance und Reliability-Features in diesen Netatalk 2.1.
Die aber jetzt in der 205 so noch nicht drin sind?
Nee, da ist nur dieses Log-Steel drin, damit es überhaupt grundsätzlich erstmal geht. Und ich habe das jetzt genau seit zwei Wochen, also letztens wirklich eine Stunde nach der Sendung, habe ich das gemacht und es ging gleich sofort. Ich war fast ein bisschen enttäuscht, weil es ging so scheiße schnell und einfach und ich musste gar nichts mehr basteln und fummen. Aber ich freue mich jedes Mal, wenn ich so abends im Bett sitze und noch so ein bisschen chatte und auf einmal sehe ich, wie dieses Image gemountet wird. Das kommt ja dann auch gleich in diesen Grünen so. Dann dreht er ja kurz hier gegen den Uhrzeigersinn, da oben ist im Menü und zack, der mountet das wieder weg und dann, also unmountet und dann denkst du, ja, Backup ist wieder durch. Also das ist einfach ein cooles Gefühl. Du brauchst dich nicht mehr kümmern. Nur mit diesem Firewall, das ist noch ein bisschen blöd, aber das war ja vorher auch so, aber da müsste man noch mal irgendwie demnächst sich was anderes einfallen lassen.
Da hatte ich ja extrem Ärger, nachdem ich wieder meinen Clean-Install gemacht hatte und danach meine Platte anders hieß. Dann irgendwie Time Machine läuft dann wieder an, trifft dann auf dieser Time Capsule auf viele alte Backups.
Der Main-Order ist halt dein Rechner-Name.
Ja, aber es habe 14 Tage gebraucht, bis das Ding endlich mal wieder ein vollständiges Time Machine-Backup hinbekommen hat.
Weil es mal abgebrochen hat zwischendurch?
Ja, weil es einfach so ewig alles irgendwie lief.
Du gewingst auf das Time Capsule, aber... Unklar.
Aber hier, du hast jetzt dieses... Also der legt jetzt so ein Image auf einem ZFS an und...
Also mein Router hat einen ZFS, aber es könnte doch irgendwas anderes sein.
Aber du hast jetzt einen ZFS-Router, der über Netatalk, AFP, deinem Rechner ermöglicht, mit Time Machine und so weiter. Ich verstehe, das ist ja auf jeden Fall...
Prinzipiell ist das Ding wie so eine Time Capsule.
Die kurze Story ist einfach, ich mounte da ein Volume von einer anderen Kisse und sag dem Time Machine, er soll sein Backup drauf machen. Zack, fertig, mehr ist es gar nicht. Das ist die kurze Version. So will man es haben. Und ab da macht das halt von allein. Das heißt, der mountet das von allein und das ging halt alles vorher nicht so richtig. Und ich hab weder Bourgeois irgendwie was gemacht, dass er sich announced, weil braucht man nicht. Also ist vielleicht cool, damit man... damit Leute nicht mal mehr mounten müssen, sondern dass sie gleich sehen, so wie eine Time Capsule. Die bietet sich halt schon per Bourgeois an.
Weil du klappst deinen Rechner auf, er weiß, das Ding ist da, und dann macht er halt was.
Ja, und das feature hab ich halt nicht, aber wie gesagt, das ist nur beim ersten Mal, dass man es einmal von Hand losstarten muss. Und sonst...
Gut, dann basteln wir uns jetzt alle unsere ZFS-Time-Capsules.
Ich hatte auch gestern noch mal kurz mit Kurt zu sprechen, dieses Freenas, das ist wohl auch durchaus gut benutzbar. Ich hab das jetzt selber noch nicht in der Hand gehabt.
Wenn die auf Netatalk 205 schwenken, was ja demnächst mal rauskommen müsste, weil RC3 ist ja schon, dann zack, müsste das da auch gleich sofort gehen.
Dann ist das so langsam die Lösung. Ich grübe da nämlich jetzt echt drüber nach, ob ich mir mal so eine Box kaufe, damit ich dieses begloppte Roboteimer loswerde, dass ich mir einfach so eine Box kaufe, wo halt ein PC mit drin ist, vier Platten-Slots, wo man dann irgendwie schöne, dicke, fette 2TB-Platten reinschieben kann und dann macht man da irgendwie so ein, was weiß ich, so ein Doppel-ZFS-Mirror oder sogar ein Ray-Z oder so was und dann hat man da irgendwie mal Daten.
Ja, und jetzt kommt's, Max muss jetzt mal wieder weghören, demnächst in Netatalk 2.1 kommt dann auch noch Support für ZFS. Leider nicht irgendwie Snapshot-Shit oder so, das wäre ja richtig geil, aber dass sie zumindestens die Extended Attributes von ZFS benutzen, um da ihre Netatalk-Metadaten zu speichern, also zurzeit benutzen die ja da so eine Berkeley-Database oder irgendwie so um, ich weiß gar nicht, was sie da noch speichern, so tief hab ich mir da irgendwie nie reingeguckt, aber es ist irgendwie voll immer Action, was die da machen und ich nehme an, dass sie das Zeug dann einfach in den ZFS Extended Attributes abspeichern und diese Datenbank dann wegfällt.
Das würde eigentlich total Sinn machen. Ich meine, wenn sie das machen, dann wird es richtig gut. Das ist ja eigentlich genau das, was ich immer erwartet habe, dass man etwas, dass man quasi AFP spricht, aber die Speicherung der Dateien ZFS-aware macht und das eben so speichert, wie das ZFS eigentlich, wie sich das gehört. Und wenn sie sozusagen auch wissen, auf welchem Fallsystem sie arbeiten und nicht nur so diffus irgendwie, ich hab da mal ein Unix-Fallsystem und ich mach irgendwas irgendwie, dann ist das eigentlich eine sehr schöne Sache. Das ist cool, das gefällt mir. Ich glaub, ich will das haben.
Das ist total rock'n'roll.
Nur, dass wir kein ZFS im Mac haben werden.
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Und was noch kommt, jetzt tun wir uns noch ein bisschen über ZFS kurz labern. Nur ganz kurz. Und zwar haben die bei ZFS, der Oberfuzziler, dieser Jeff Bornwick, habt ihr ja schon viel gehört, der hat letztens einen sogenannten D-Duplication Support committed in den Code. Der kommt so in einem Monat dann im ersten Open Solaris Express raus und ich hoffe dann ein bisschen später dann auch irgendwann mal ein Freebies-D. Und zwar sorgt das dafür, die merken sich einfach von jedem Block den Hash. Und das machen sie ja sowieso schon, dass jeder Block einen Hash hat, weil sie ja da dran überprüfen, ob der Block noch okay ist oder nicht. Und diese Hashes merken die sich. Und wenn er dann einen Block irgendwie von deinem Mac zum Beispiel über das Backup irgendwie, wenn der ankommt und der gespeichert werden soll, dann macht er halt auch wieder den Hash und checkt aber gleich in seiner Hash-Datenbank, ob es den Block auf der Platte schon gibt. Und wenn ja, speichert er den nicht, sondern nur so einen kleinen Link, so habe ich schon, der liegt da und da. Das heißt ja auch hier bei unserem Time Machine Backup.
Das heißt, du duplizierst eine Datei und es geht instantan sofort, weil er irgendwie überhaupt gar nichts doppelt ablegt, sondern mehr oder weniger dieselben Daten.
Er muss halt für jeden Block immer noch speichern, dass es davon halt schon einen gibt. Da muss er ein paar Sachen schon noch abspeichern.
Drei Gigabyte-Datei irgendwie duplizieren ist dann einfach ein paar Megabyte Metadaten und das war's.
So macht das ja zum Beispiel Git, also hier, Distributed Version Control ja auch ganz genauso. Wenn du da halt irgendwie eine Datei eincheckst, wo es einfach genau schon so diesen Blob mit diesem Hash gibt, dann macht er da auch nur, ja hab ich schon da.
Time Machine ist ja schon nicht schlecht, weil wir wissen ja, hatten wir auch in irgendeiner Sendung schon, dass du hast, was nehmen wir da, wir nehmen jetzt mal so ein Stück Musik irgendwie, oder hier so eine, was haben wir hier, unsere Aufnahme von unserer Sendung hier, sagen wir mal, die ist 100 Megabyte groß. Und du hast die jetzt schon in deinem Backup, der hat die da abgespeichert, so dann stellst du fest, jetzt hast du hier deine Kapitelmarken bekommen und du änderst jetzt die 100 Megabyte-Datei und fügst noch hier diese Kapitelmarken ein. Die sind wahrscheinlich nur am Anfang oder am Ende der Datei, weil er wird die ja nicht überall mitten drin speichern. Richtig, aber er speichert sie halt irgendwo an einer Stelle. So, dann legt dein Backup wieder los und das Time Machine Backup ist halt eben nicht block-based, sondern nur file-based. Das heißt, für die Time Machine ist das ganze File geändert, das heißt, er wird das ganze File irgendwie zum Server übertragen und wird es nochmal neu speichern. Also 100 Megabyte, die da nochmal rumliegen würden. So, das ZFS aber zerhackt natürlich die 100 Megabyte in dieser einzelnen Blöcke, so maximal immer bis 128 Kilobyte und würde dann bei 99,9 Prozent der Blöcke von dieser Audio-Datei feststellen, ist ja immer noch so wie vorher und würde dank D-Dope die einfach nicht mehr abspeichern und zack, wären unsere Backups ordentlich kleiner. Und das ist so nebenbei, also man muss nichts machen, man muss nur einschalten, fertig.
Ich bin immer noch total angepisst, dass es keinen ZFS geben wird auf dem Mac. Aber das ist einfach so schlimm. Büchse hat mir gestern noch mal seine Time Machine-artige Backup-Lösung, die er jetzt irgendwie mit FreeBSD realisiert hat, beschrieben und das ist das, so wie man es haben will. Seine Büchse macht halt einfach Backups über SSH, also erstmal save und so und geht irgendwie halt einfach übers Netz. Und dazu nutzt sie halt einfach diesen Snapshot-Kram von ZFS und das halt alle fünf Minuten. Das heißt, du machst alle fünf Minuten einfach einen Snapshot, weil das kostet nicht viel. Du machst irgendwie dann alle fünf Minuten einfach einen Backup, was halt in der Regel immer so ein paar Bytes sind. Das heißt, du kannst auch mal eben deinen Rechner irgendwo auf dem Hotspot aufklappen, irgendwie fünf Minuten bevor dein Zug fährt und du kannst davon ausgehen, dass du einfach mal einen Backup hast von vor fünf Minuten, weil das einfach so kleine Diffs sind, die auch noch total safe sind und nicht so ewig dauert wie mit Time Machine.
Aber wahrscheinlich muss man einfach auf den Jonathan Schwarz, heißt der so, der ehemalige Sun-Chef? Also es gibt ja auch Stimmen, die sagen, die den Stinkefinger Richtung Jonathan Schwarz halten, weil der das irgendwie halt verkackt hat. Oder irgendwie nicht, da weiß ich nicht, irgendwie.
Also ich weiß nicht, gibt es da irgendwelche...
Irgendwas von Lizenzproblemen gehört, oder?
Ja, das war ja schon, hatten wir ja letztes Mal schon irgendwie, dass sie sich da irgendwie nicht einigen konnten. Und die These wohl so weit auch bestätigt ist, dass Apple da halt nicht irgendwie nur CDDL-License machen wollte, sondern irgendwie...
Sie wollten irgendwie eine spezielle Lizenz haben, damit sie halt irgendwie...
Vor den NetApp-Patentklagen sicher sind. Und da wollten sie sich wohl mit Apple einigen, mit Sun einigen und das hat wohl nicht geklappt. Und dann haben die Typen so rumgerätselt in so einem Forum und dann meinte auch wieder dieser Jeff Bonwick, der da der Oberguru von ZFS ist. Er meinte, er könnte nichts sagen, aber das wäre ungefähr die Essenz von all dem.
Ja, aber diese Essenz, die da auf die sich bezog, das hat ja nichts mit dem Patent zu tun, sondern dass Apple eine spezielle Lizenz oder einen speziellen Support haben wollte für ZFS.
Weiß man halt nicht.
Wenn man halt in sein Fallsystem...
Aber die Essenz ist halt, dass sie sich nicht einigen konnten.
Ja, die konnten sich nicht einigen. Das ist wirklich hardcore.
Die haben da schon ein paar Leute eingestellt, die es auch bei Sun abgeworben haben. Die haben da schon ein bisschen was reingesteckt und dass sie es dann so von heute auf morgen droppen, ohne Back-Up-Plan, also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, aber ohne dass sie ein anderes Fallsystem gerade am Start haben. Oder zumindest wissen wir von dem noch nicht. Unklar.
Ja, also da muss schon irgendwann auch grob schief gegangen sein.
Ja, und vor allem ist es ja auch absehbar, dass bei diesem ZFS da geht einfach die Arbeit auch weiter. Also da hängt jetzt schon so eine riesen Community dran und eigentlich alle Leute, die irgendwie halbwegs sinnvolle Fallsysteme haben wollen, arbeiten jetzt damit.
Ja, und es gibt ja übrigens das, letztens haben wir noch irgendwie gesagt, hier gibt ja noch dieses Butter FS von Oracle, wo irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wer das gesagt hat, aber irgendjemand meinte, das wird gar nicht mehr weiterentwickelt, aber ist gar nicht so.
Es wird auch weiterentwickelt schon, aber nicht von Oracle. Oracle ist ausgestiegen, die haben das Projekt wohl losgetreten, haben sich dann aber irgendwann dann davon zurückgezogen.
Aber es soll halt das nächste Linux-FS sein, was Ext halt ablöst. Also auch der Ext-Entwickler sozusagen, der Haupttragende, der hat auch schon gesagt, dass Ext 4 jetzt wohl erstmal das letzte ist und dann alles auf Butter-Riff-S geht.
Aber es wird wohl noch eine Weile dauern, weil es ist ja noch voll frisch, es tropft ja noch. Da schmilzt die Butter noch.
Das ist ja auch eine Linux-Lizenz, das wird ja noch viel weniger.
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, was Apples Plan sein kann.
Half-SX?
Half-SX-Treme.
Aber was wollen sie da anderes einbauen als in ZFS? Na gut, ich glaube doch, diesen Artikel, der da irgendwie bei Butter-FS noch so den einen oder anderen Aspekt hat. Hast du das verstanden?
Also der eine Artikel, was ich ja auch schon in dem Podcast gesagt habe, dass das ZFS auch nicht so richtig für Apple irgendwie auch gepasst hat, so auf Anhieb, weil eben zum Beispiel braucht es halt viel RAM und so.
Aber haben wir doch alle.
Ja, dein iPhone hat nicht viel RAM.
Da brauchen wir uns ja auch erstmal nicht.
Naja.
Aber willst du dein iPhone noch auf Half-S haben, wenn irgendwie, also wenn die ihr Fallsystem wechseln, dann wechseln sie es auch richtig.
Ja, ich...
Also nur für Server jetzt ein neues Bild.
Also ich weiß, welchen Bericht du meinst, aber der kam mir so vor wie so ein Apple-Jünger, der irgendwie jetzt nicht das Spielzeug kriegt, was er will und deswegen macht das ja auch gleich schlecht, weil Apple hat es nicht genommen, also kann es, ja. Das, das, ich weiß nicht, so geht es auch nicht.
Ja, aber es ist halt ja auch so, ne? Also irgendwie einen ZFS auf einer Kiste jetzt zu fahren, was weniger als 2 GB RAM hat, macht halt keinen Spaß.
Wie viel RAM nimmt das denn?
Ist so, die sagen selber auf der Seite, FreeBSD-Wiki hier, irgendwie 2 GB. Also ich meine, das ist ja nicht alles...
Ich hab das vorher auf meiner Kiste gefahren, die hatte 512 MB.
Das ist ja nichts, was man nicht noch tunen kann, aber nichtsdestotrotz...
Und die iPhones sind jetzt auch schon bei 256. Also ich meine wirklich, mein iPhone ist bald... Also das nächste iPhone wird schneller sein als der Router, den ich noch letztes Jahr zu Hause für meinen ganzen Stuff benutzt habe.
Naja, nichtsdestotrotz können wir uns, glaube ich, einfach damit abfinden, dass es das nicht gibt.
Ja, aber sie müssten mit HFSX, nehmen wir es jetzt einfach mal so, das müssten sie, das ist ja sowas wie... Keine Ahnung, da müssen sie halt auch voll mit Open Source gehen. Da müssen sie irgendwie FileKit draus machen und quasi nochmal so eine Webkit-Geschichte lostreten.
Aber machen sie jetzt, wie gesagt, hier zum Beispiel mit diesem Grand Central Dispatch, hat ja auch erstmal keiner gedacht, dass er das irgendwie zum Beispiel Open Source macht. Und ich glaube, die gehen da schon auf diese Schiene, dass wenn sie Support dafür haben wollen, dass sie dann sagen, hier Open Source, bitteschön.
Genau, Open Source, HFS, da werden sie alle sofort raufstürzen.
Na, wenn es cool ist.
Wenn es cool ist, dann ist es was, was irgendwie komplett neu gemacht wird und nicht irgendwie immer draufgeklatscht, draufgeklatscht, draufgeklatscht. Und wenn es neu ist, dann ist es viel zu frisch, dann wird es auch erstmal 5 Jahre keiner anfassen. Außer sie sind schon seit 5 Jahren dabei, kann aber nicht sein, weil die entwickeln ja nicht ZFS und HFS, irgendwas irgendwie parallel. Also es haut irgendwie alles nicht so richtig hin. Würde ich mal sagen, wir wissen einfach nicht, was da abgeht und dann müssen wir mal weiter gucken.
Ja, wir wissen es nicht. Aber ich dränge darauf, dass da was passiert ist. Auf jeden Fall.
Es muss was passieren.
Ein System, ein Fallsystem zu haben, was kein Copyright hat, was keine Snapshots hat.
Kein Shacksumming und was irgendwie kaputt gehen kann, das geht nicht.
Das geht einfach gar nicht mehr.
21. Jahrhundert.
Jahrhundert, jetzt bitte Apple sofort. Sonst müssen wir euch einfach...
Ganz böse drohen.
Ja, genau.
Und das war damals schon cool.
Eine Woche Kauf-Boycott.
Genau, wir kaufen alle eine Woche lang keine neuen Produkte mehr.
Wir laden uns vielleicht mal eine Ubuntu-CD runter.
Wir lassen eine Sendung ausfallen.
Und wir fordern alle Hörer auf, sich auf dem Boycott anzuschließen.
Das wird es jetzt rumreißen.
Aber ich weiß noch, wie die iPods, die kamen ja damals raus mit Half-S und dann kamen ja irgendwie so ein bisschen später Half-S mit Journaling raus und da hab ich mit meinem iPod irgendwie auch einen Rechner angeschlossen und der kam ja noch direkt als Volumen auf dem Rechner und da hab ich gesagt, okay, mach mal das Journaling, da muss man so einen Kommand oder irgendwie absetzen oder irgendwas, muss man irgendwie so von Hand einschalten, mach mal Journaling auf iPod und zack. Und das ging dann auch gleich und so, yeah.
Wofür braucht man denn das denn?
Das brauchen wir nicht, aber es ging halt. Und so habt ihr es schlecht, man will natürlich dann irgendwann auch ZDFs mal auf seinem iPhone haben, aber das kann man ja auch noch nicht mal als Volumen ranmachen, habt ihr irgendwie 10, 20 Gigabyte auf meinem iPhone frei und kann sie nicht irgendwie benutzen, um da mein Zeug rumzuschleppen.
Ich glaube, die wollen einfach, wenn sie jetzt ihr Fallsystem nochmal irgendwie neu machen, dann wollen sie es einfach auch so richtig future-proof auf allen Geräten.
Ja, aber wie lange soll das dauern, bis man so einen kompletten Fallsystem hat? Also dieses ZFS ist seit 2000 oder 2000, eine einzelne Entwicklung.
Ich weiß, du.
Auch wenn wir jetzt gerade so viel quatschen, ist das schon viel älter als man denkt.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Und so ein Fallsystem willst du nicht nehmen, wenn das irgendwie noch tropft und trieft und...
Aber weißt du, das ist ja alles open source. Die können ja dann auch kopieren, wie sie wollen. Also die können ja auch ganz viel von ZFS dann einfach so einsammeln.
Ja, aber dafür wollten sie extra die eigene Lizenz.
Vielleicht pokern die da auch nur gerade ganz schwer, sitzen schon längst alle wieder am Verhandlungstisch und schieben sich da Dollars hin und her und keine Ahnung und vielleicht macht es irgendwann einen Klick und dann geht es einfach weiter. Wer weiß, wer weiß.
Wir können jetzt mal dein zweites Toker-Thema vielleicht auch...
Also ich meine, das hängt ja dann eigentlich an Larry Ellison und ich meine, der old Steve und der Larry, die kennen sich.
Ich meine, das Problem ist, der hat erst mal noch gar nichts zu sagen, weil er ist ja noch nicht durch.
Macht er das immer noch nicht durch?
Nee, Europa zickt rum und sagt, hm, finden wir irgendwie nicht so richtig gut.
Ah, vielleicht warten sie da drauf, dass es dann endlich durch ist, weil dann holt sich Steve irgendwie den Larry einfach in seine unmobilierte Wohnung.
Dann sagt er, hör zu, wir machen dir ein geiles Apple-Ruder für deine dicke Jacht. Oder irgendwie so.
Ja, der wird einfach in das Reality-Distortion-Field eingetaucht.
Ich glaube, der hat seine eigene.
Und zwar so richtig irgendwie, wie man so Cowboys früher so in den Getränke-Druck, den Trank-Druck da von den Pferden irgendwie reingedrückt hat, was so hinten am Schlawitchen packen und rein und so kommt Larry Ellison dann in diese Realitätsschleuder.
Ich glaube, er kommt eher in die Realitätsschleuder, wenn man jetzt hier noch weiterfällt.
Okay, zweite Joker-Thema, ja? Schneller?
Na ja, da haben wir jetzt schon wieder ein, jetzt auf der Uhr, ne?
Die haben ja auch vorher spät angefangen. Erst um drei oder noch später, oder?
Na ja gut, die zwei Stundenlatter haben wir schon vor einiger Zeit gelassen.
Okay, nächste Thema. Also, was hab ich noch gemacht?
Komm her, Baby. Ihr seht das jetzt gerade nicht, wir laufen jetzt gerade im Kreis, die Wände hochspringen sozusagen in Zeitlupe, während sich unsere Mäntel schön im Wind plattern aufhalten und...
Und Dennis steht so da wie so ein Bruce Lee mit der Hand hier so, mit so...
Wisst ihr, dass ich Matrix...
Bring it all nach links und die Kurbel fliegen an ihm vorbei.
So, ich kann Matrix, ganz kurz verschliessen, ich kann Matrix nicht mehr ernst nehmen, seitdem mir aufgefallen ist, dass die deutsche Synchronsprecherin von der, wie heißt die Hauptdarstellerin, diese schwarzhaarige da, die gleiche...
Trinity.
Die gleiche Synchron-Stimme ist wie die Mutter bei Malcolm Mittendrin. Malcolm Mittendrin, das ist eine sehr, sehr lustige Serie, aber die Mutter ist halt da total unerträglich und bei Matrix hat ja dieser Trinity schon so eine gewisse Grundsexiness. Also du guckst so synchronisierte Filme? Ja, ich hab den mal synchronisiert gesehen und seitdem denke ich immer, wenn ich Trinity sehe, denke ich immer an die Mutter aus Malcolm Mittendrin. So, Neo, steh endlich auf, du musst zur Schule!
Also synchronisierte Spielfilme, das ist irgendwie das Fett 32-Jähr-Unterhaltung.
Ja, ich hab schon mal synchronisiert und zu Filmen geguckt.
Die neunschwänzige Kabelpeitsche. Los, Dennis, jetzt hier.
Also.
Da war ja hier so, also Tim ist ja nicht so Fan davon, aber alle anderen wollen ja nicht, dass irgendwie jeder alle möglichen Daten mal so mitsniffen kann, wenn man irgendwie so unterwegs ist im digitalen Netz.
Zum Beispiel, du bist ein Fan von?
Ich bin da total verfahren.
Nein, du bist doch irgendwie so, mir ist doch alles egal. War das nicht so?
Jetzt erzähl erst mal, was du da erzählen willst. Dann kommentiere ich das mal.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du halt in so einem Café sitzt und da dir einen WLAN benutzt, dann könnte ja auch da einer sitzen, der irgendwie auch den WLAN benutzt und all deinen Scheiß, den du da mit dem iPhone irgendwie überträgst.
Ah, klar.
Mein Mail ist natürlich verschlüsselt und anders geht es auch gar nicht, weil ich halt irgendwie so einen Superadmin habe, der sich darum kümmert, dass das alles noch schick ist.
Ja, meiner auch.
Ja, aber es gibt halt Leute, die haben irgendwie einen Mail-Server, der irgendwie nicht Krypto macht und den die dann so normal holen und wo man zum Beispiel Mails mitlesen könnte. Oder Twitter-Refix zum Beispiel, ist das eigentlich verschlüsselt?
Die meisten Twitter-Klans gehen über HTTPS.
Ist das inzwischen so?
Ich kenne nicht alle, ich habe nicht alle irgendwie gecheckt.
Ja, ich könnte es dir vorstellen, da gibt es auch eine Menge... Siehst du, da geht es schon los. Man wäselt halt einfach nicht. Und ist alles nicht immer so schlimm. Aber so richtig super Fahrgefühl kommt mir da zumindest nicht auf. Und man will sich ja nur so ein bisschen drum kümmern. Das muss ja eigentlich alles gar nicht sein. Das könnte ja irgendwie auch mal eigentlich verschlüsselt stattfinden.
Du hast dir einen VPN eingerichtet.
Und da hab ich mir einen VPN eingerichtet.
Hast du den Spannungsbogen zerstört?
Nee, der wär jetzt genauer gekommen. So, ihr habt das früher schon mal probiert. Es gibt ja drei verschiedene VPN-Möglichkeiten auf dem iPhone und zwar dieses L2TP, dann gibt es noch dieses PPTP und dann gibt es noch das Cisco IPSEC. Hast du was vertauscht? L2TP ist nicht Cisco-Kram.
Soweit ich weiß, ist dieses L2TP auch mal von Cisco erfunden worden.
Das kann sein, aber das ist...
Cisco VPN ist dann nochmal später...
Also auf dem iPhone ist es auf jeden Fall von links nach rechts irgendwie L2TP, PPTP und Cisco IPSEC nennt man das.
PPTP ist von Microsoft.
Genau, so dieses PPTP habe ich mir nie weiter angeguckt und dieses L2TP, da habe ich mal so ein bisschen gegoogelt schon irgendwie letztes Jahr und da gab es auf dem Mac so ein Tool, das hieß iVPN. Das ist nix weiter als ein GUI-Wrapper für einen Command-Line-Tool, was es eigentlich auf OS X Server gibt. Und auf OS X Server gibt es von Apple auch einen GUI dafür, nur auf dem Desktop nicht. Und der hat halt da so einen Wrapper geschrieben. Kannst du halt irgendwie dir einklicken und dann kannst du da mit deinem iPhone jetzt, ich verkürze das mal ein bisschen, kannst du da connecten und hast ein VPN zu deinem Desktop halt hin. Aber ich glaube auch halt irgendwie nur einer. Und das hat schon so ganz gut funktioniert, aber war auch irgendwie nicht so richtig cool, weil mein Desktop ist halt nicht mein Router, sondern mein Laptop und wenn ich den mit dabei habe, dann hätte ich nix mehr, wo ich mit meinem iPhone hinconnecten könnte. Naja, das ist dann auch noch so, dass dieses Ivy-Band-Tool hat ja irgendwann nicht mehr, gibt es nicht mehr als freien Download, sondern du willst irgendwie Code dafür haben, wenn du es benutzt, obwohl es eigentlich nur so ein GUI-Wrapper ist für so ein Command-Land-Tool, fand ich ein bisschen scheiße. Jedenfalls war nicht so die tolle Lösung so. Und dann habe ich letzte Woche gedacht hier, weil ich auch immer ein bisschen mit IPsec rumspiele und so, dieses Cisco-IPsec, was machen die denn da so Besonderes, dass irgendwie nur Cisco das irgendwie kann? Also gibt es halt so von Cisco-Geräte, gibt es so kleine Kisten für keine Ahnung, 300 Euro, da kannst du zehn Leute mit irgendwie fürs iPhone VPN machen. Und dann gibt es größere Geräte, wenn du es für 250 Leute haben willst, die kosten irgendwie ein paar tausend Euro. Und so, man kann aber IPsec auch mit seinem FreeBearSD-Router machen, den ich ja nur mal habe. Habe es ein bisschen rumgespielt mit meinem Kumpel, Admin. Und haben wir irgendwie herausgefunden, was man da so für Configs in diesem Raccoon setzen muss. Der Raccoon kümmert sich, dass dieses IPsec aufgesetzt wird. Und dann haben wir irgendwie 2-3 Tage gebastelt. Und siehe da, irgendwann hat es Chaka gemacht. Und dann hatten wir halt VPN auf dem iPhone. Dann haben wir noch ein bisschen weiter gebastelt, damit es irgendwie noch einfacher ist. Und zwar muss man sich so Zerts erstellen, denn diese Unterschreiben mit so Master-Root-Dingens-Zerts, wie auch immer die heißen. Und die lädt man aufs iPhone drauf, indem man die einfach ansurft mit dem Safari. Dann sagt er, hier hab ich einen Zert gefunden, willst du das Zert installieren? Dann hast du es direkt drauf. SSL-Zerts, oder was?
Man kann auf dem iPhone...
Zerts installieren. Pass auf, ich zeig das jetzt mal kurz. Jeder Developer wird es ja schon kennen.
Auch dieser CA-Zert-Kram und so?
Ja, es gibt in den Einstellungen ganz unten, wenn man ein bisschen runterscrollt, kurz vor Reset, gibt es die Profiles. Die Developer kennen das schon, weil zum Developen muss man Developer-Profiles installieren, also Ad-Hoc-Profile, Debug-Profile und so weiter. Und das ist auch genau die Stelle, wo die... Ihr kennt ja auch die Carrier-Profiles, richtig? Mit Tethering und so. Die sind ja auch genau in dem gleichen Ding gelandet. Und da werden jetzt bei mir, bei den Configuration-Profiles aufgelistet. Ich hab hier ein iPhone CA und ein Identity-Certificate. Kann ich auch draufklicken. Und dann kommen die und dann nochmal More Details machen und dann nochmal und dann zeigt der hier diese riesen Latte an Zeug an und das hört auch gar nicht mehr auf. Also er zeigt irgendwie das Ganze, ups, das gesamte zerrt da irgendwie an. Wo ist es jetzt?
Okay, das ist aber so ein Zertifikat, wie du das für HTTPS auch verwenden würdest.
Ich glaub ja, müsste jetzt nochmal...
In was für einem Format hast du das da rausgehauen? Da gibt es ja auch PEM und DER und...
Das eine hieß Punkt P12. Und das andere hieß, glaube ich, CART. Also Jungs, ihr könnt auch CARTs auf eure iPhones hochladen.
Also PEM-Format kann der Mobile Safari, das war mir ganz neu, ich dachte, das hätten sie weggelassen, aber das ist ja schön.
Jedenfalls, bei diesem Cisco IPsec kann man entweder mit Passwort machen und mit Shared Secret. Aber mit Shared Secret muss dann die Gegenseite schon immer die IP-Adresse von dem iPhone wissen, wo es gerade ist. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd, weil man weiß ja nicht, wo man gerade ist.
Mal langsam den Pferden, den muss man ein bisschen zurückspulen, damit wir das irgendwie nochmal richtig hinkriegen. Also du wolltest ja eigentlich nur einen VPN machen. Wozu brauchst du denn überhaupt dieses Zert?
Ok, das erkläre ich ja gerade. Und zwar das IPsec, man macht sich so seine Konfig.
Oder anders gefragt, warum brauchst du jetzt IPsec? Ach, für das Cisco VPN.
Damit ich dieses Cisco VPN...
Weil Cisco VPN quasi IPsec ist.
Ja, definitiv. Und zwar, also L2TP ist auch so ein Standard. Aber der ist nicht verschlüsselt. Deswegen packen die das in IPsec ein. Und ich glaube bei PPTP auch. Die sind so PPP in IPsec eingepackt. Oder irgendwie so, damit du deinen Traffic transportieren kannst. Man kann das natürlich aber auch, wenn man ein bisschen komplizierte Setups hat, kann man das IPsec aber auch pur machen. Da geht das ja auch alles. Ist halt ein bisschen komplexer mit den Einstellungen. Weil IPsec eigentlich gedacht war, für zwei Firmenetz, in zwei verschiedene Lokalitäten, wo man die Adressen, wo die immer fest sind und immer fest bleiben, dass man sich da in einen IPsec-Tunnel macht. Und dann ist alles schick. Das iPhone hat aber nicht eine feste Adresse. Das ist heute mal hier, morgen mal da und übermorgen woanders. Und man weiß auch nicht, wo man ist. Deswegen kann der Server, wo man sich hinconnecten will, der kann ja nicht wissen, wo du bist. Und deswegen kann man da nicht mit einem sogenannten Shared Secret arbeiten. Weil der Server dann nie wüsste, für wen er das denn jetzt nun rausholen sollte, das Secret. Deswegen gibt es diese Serts. Die installierst du dann auf dem iPhone und dann kannst du sozusagen von diesem Shared Secret umschalten auf Sert. Und das hinterlegst du auch auf dem Server, dann weiß alles klar, das ist jetzt genau das iPhone und dafür hole ich genau folgende Einstellungen hier aus meiner Datei. Und dann lege ich da mit dem IPsec los. Dann wird da eine Adresse übertragen, es wird ein DNS übertragen und dann hast du deinen VPN und dafür braucht man diese Serts. Und da ist irgendwie gar nichts Spezielles dran, es ist einfach IPsec mit Sert-Authentifizierung. Und was CISCO noch da speziell macht, ist, dass sie da so Vendo-IDs irgendwie beim IPsec-Initialisieren so mit übertragen. Die musste halt hier dieser Raccoon können und das können die aber schon seit ein paar Jahren. Und deswegen können die sich prima miteinander unterhalten. Weil IPsec ist schon ein relativ festgenagelter Standard. Da kann man jetzt nicht so viel anders machen.
Aber was ich jetzt nicht verstanden habe, wenn ich jetzt PPTP oder L2TP mache, dann ist doch auch alles verschlüsselt, was ich darüber schicke. Was ist denn jetzt bei diesem CISCO VPN so sehr viel teurer, dass man sich diesen Aufwand jetzt machen will?
Na, das L2TP wollte ich auch erst probieren auf meinem FreeBSD, weil das ist nun mal der Stelle, wo ich hinconnecten will, zu mir nach Hause nämlich. Aber das L2TP habe ich geguckt auf FreeBSD, da gibt es irgendeinen Client, das ist eine Linux-Software, selbst wenn man nichts gegen Linux hat, aber diese Software, die war einfach, also grottenschlecht, wäre noch geschmeichelt. Das war einfach unter aller Sau und irgendwie Doku habe ich nicht so richtig, kannst ja mal so ein bisschen in Source gucken und ja, wenn du Glück hast, dann läuft es irgendwie so Software. Da hatte ich irgendwie mal so gar keinen Bock drauf. Also ich habe das aufgemacht, mir eine Viertelstunde mal drüber geguckt und dann dachte ich, ne, also das tue ich mir jetzt nicht an und habe irgendwie weiter versucht an diesen Cisco IPsec Weg und das ging ja dann auch reichlich schneller.
Also das war sozusagen deine FreeBSD spezifische Problematik, wenn man jetzt nicht VPN einfach nur für sein iPhone aufmachen will und man hat einen Mac?
Dann könnte man dieses iVPN-Tool benutzen, geht aber nicht, also geht schon, aber der Typ will halt dafür 15 Pfund oder irgendwie so haben und das geht mal gar nicht. Wenn man einen OS X Server hat, da müsste es eigentlich Bild-in sein, dieses Tool, VPN, weiß nicht, wie sie es genau nennen. Und da klickst du das halt einfach und dann müsste es eigentlich out of the box gehen und dann machst du es halt mit mit.
Also unter Mac OS X Server, man nimmt das Server-Admin, also wenn man sich jetzt so ein Mac Mini gekauft hat, da hat man das auch gleich mit drin.
Da müsste man es mit drin haben und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute da dann connecten können, aber mit dem iPhone wird es reichen.
Mit dem iPhone wird es reichen.
Ja, aber ich will es ja dann auch für mehrere haben.
Das ist aber an sich extrem zu empfehlen. Also wenn man zu Hause seinen Router so macht, dann welche Ports muss man da, weißt du das?
Für L2TP?
Oder für PWTP?
Also für L2TP ist es glaube ich der Port 1701. Und weil das ja dann am Ende aber in IPSEC eingepackt wird, IPSEC ist irgendwie noch UDP-Port 500 und wenn man noch irgendwie Nut Traversal hat, obwohl ich weiß nicht, ob die es bei L2TP auch haben, dann muss man noch Port 4500 freischalten und dann muss man noch das Protokoll ESP freischalten, weil TCP und UDP ist ja eins, aber damit IPSEC ist ESP und das muss man dann auch noch...
Also wenn dieses IVP inhaltlich cool wäre, dann würde es auch gleich noch dem Router Bescheid sagen und dass es gleich die richtigen Ports auch noch öffnet.
Naja, wenn du auf dem Router eine Firewall hast und da irgendwelche Tools installierst, dann musst du ja eh immer für alle möglichen Tools den entsprechenden Port aufmachen.
Ja gut, aber die Software kann ja heutzutage dem Router das selber sagen, was es macht. Das muss man ja nicht unbedingt selber tun. Also die Software könnte wirklich dahin gehen und sagen...
Also wenn meine Firewall remote gesteuert werden könnte, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das so gut finde, können ja alle Tools sich alles Mögliche aufmachen. Nee, lass mal.
Ja, die können eh alles nachher draußen übertragen. Von daher ist das albern. Na gut, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall geht das ja mit NUT-PMP und so weiter. Warum muss man das selber machen, wenn man es sich auch machen lassen könnte? Also ich finde es auch ein bisschen teuer, dieses Tool auf der anderen Seite, wer jetzt wirklich irgendwie mal eben VPN anmachen will, das ist ja schon ein echter Wert, weil du kannst, also wenn du deinen Router so konfiguriert bekommen hast, dass er eben die ganzen Ports, die jetzt einfach benötigt sind, welches Protokoll man dann durchlässt, genau, dann kann man das sehr einfach auf dem iPhone einrichten und dann hat man ja einerseits einen verschlüsselten Zugang, egal wo man ist, was schonmal cool ist.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du wieder in irgendeinem Land bist, wo die das mit dem Filtern ein bisschen ernst nehmen, weiß nicht, was ich letztens gehört habe, irgendwo in den Emiraten oder sonst wo, wo du nicht auf YouTube oder sonst wie zugreifen kannst, da machst du irgendwie VPN nach Hause, wenn das dann durchgeht, vielleicht auch nicht, vielleicht Filtern ist ja auch gleich weg, aber zumindest kannst du von irgendwie, wenn du mal in einem Netzen bist, wo du dich nicht so wohlfühlst oder auf einem Kongress zum Beispiel, da will man auf jeden Fall auch nicht...
Generelle Veranstaltungen, auch Hotspots, das ist ja geil, wenn man damit rumgammelt.
Du willst nicht, dass die Leute gerade sehen, wo du so rumklickst und du weißt nie, ob deine Tools da jetzt gerade verschlüsseln oder nicht.
Genau, eigentlich will man das immer anhaben, aber dann will man halt anhaben. Also entweder kauft man oder man kauft sich halt hier, was weiß ich, bei Swiss VPN, das funktioniert eigentlich auch ganz prima, die machen dir halt einen PPP-TP Dienst auf, da zahlst du halt irgendwie 5 Euro im Monat und hast halt einfach auch gleich diese Server-Problematik nicht. Und dann hast du auch eine performante Anbindung und das rottelt jetzt nicht deinen Netzzugang durch deine eigene Leitung zu Hause.
Naja, das iPhone macht dann jetzt nicht so viel Traffic, das stimmt schon, aber das geht.
Die kann ja auch zu sein, weil zu Hause noch der bitter und läuft, dann macht es keinen Spaß.
Der läuft da eh, aber der holt ja nur Kram rein.
Wie ist denn das? Ich hatte ja schon mal so eine VPN-Lösung unter iPhone, S2, irgendwas und das hat soweit auch gut funktioniert. Man muss es bloß explizit immer einschalten. Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, dass er immer sagt...
Das ist bisher auch noch so. Ich muss es einschalten und dann bleibt es halt so lange oben, wie ich in dem Netz bin. Also wenn ich ein Netz wechsle zum Beispiel, der sagt dann nicht reconnect und macht sich das neu oder irgendwie so, dann ist es dann einfach wieder aus.
Ich dachte, jetzt mit iPhone OS 3.0 hätte sich das geändert, dass ja Auto...
Nein, ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig....
dass man für bestimmte Domains das automatisch verschalten kann.
Man kann sich Zertz machen, die sagen hier für diese Domain immer Auto-VPN sozusagen.
Also es geht dann auch nur über so ein Zertifikat.
Ja, ja, ja, es geht alles über Zertifikate. Aber wenn man das halt erstmal im Griff hat und da bin ich halt noch am basteln, dann kann sein, dass es irgendwann eines Tages, dass man sich auch vielleicht Zertifikat für alle Netze on demand macht und dann fährt er automatisch immer hoch.
Das muss man mal bloggen irgendwie, das kriegt man ja...
Ich bin ja noch nicht fertig....
aber dann muss man.
Du kannst ja mal einen Zwischenstatus bloggen.
Und das Schöne ist, dass oben im Display auch immer gleich so ein VPN-Symbol kommt zum Blaus oder ein weißes, je nachdem, wie die Status-Farbe gerade ist. Man kann auch immer genau sehen, ob man gerade in einem VPN ist oder nicht. So, das wär das.
Tja, jetzt können wir uns auch keine wirkliche richtige Hilfe geben hier aus dem Chat, weil heute ist einfach mal Bad-Net-Day.
Bad-Net-Day.
Ja, hier hab ich jetzt irgendwie... Ah, nee, ich hab Bad-Recording-Day, weil ich hier gerade irgendwie...
Ich hab alle Netze, das ist noch da. Mein Chat ist auch noch verschwunden gewesen.
Nein, mein Recorder ist gerade... Der sagt jetzt hier, memory-full. Was ist denn... Also heute ist aber auch wirklich der Wurm drin. Meine... Meine Fresse. Meine Fresse, ey. Gute Güte, warum... Ich hab das Ding noch extra......gelöscht. Bild in Memory. Memory-Stick, du Penner. Ah, ich hasse diese Technologie. Naja, so viel zum Backup-Recording. Der Stream war jetzt sozusagen deshalb leise, weil mein Recorder aufgehört hat und der schleift ja dieses Signal durch. Aber dadurch, dass wir ja nicht das Monitor-Signal hören. Das ist der Grund, warum ich einen neuen Mixer haben will. Es muss alles viel besser werden. Aber ich habe einen Plan.
Manchmal komme ich mir vor wie ein Versuchskaninchen.
Ich auch. Ich glaube, ich bin ein Versuchskaninchen. Ach, du bist auch ein Versuchskaninchen. Haben wir noch ein Thema? Nichts, ne?
Nö, eigentlich nicht so richtig, oder?
Nö, ich sehe auch nichts mehr. Ja, ich hoffe, dass wir beim nächsten Mal, also erstmal hoffe ich, dass wir einen Termin finden für das nächste Mal. Das könnte sich etwas schwierig gestalten. Und abgesehen davon, dass ich dann noch ein bisschen mehr neues Gerät habe, was wir hier ausführlich besprechen können. Das könnte sein. So denn Apple liefert. Neue iMacs in schnell sollen ja irgendwie im November kommen. Der ist noch lang. Ich hoffe, Sie meinen nicht den letzten Tag des Novembers.
Also bei Cyberport steht, dass du die Mäuse erst ab 19.11. liefern kannst.
Aber wenn du jetzt bei Apple klickst, wie gesagt, die haben vorhin...
Mehr mal klicken, dann muss ich ja tagelang warten. Ich hasse das immer. Ich will den Laden und will... Hier, Kreditkarte, gib mir Maus.
Der Herr hat Recht. Du hast Recht. Genauso will man das machen. Man will reingehen, man möchte ein Shopping-Erlebnis haben. Online kaufen ist für einen Arsch.
Du musst zum Apple Store fahren. Nach Hamburg. Und wenn ihr euch nicht bewerben wollt, dann nicht beim Apple Store arbeiten. Das wäre echt nicht gefragt, oder?
Ich glaube, dafür sind wir zu schlecht gelaunt.
Da muss man, glaube ich...
Ich bin immer gut gelaunt, aber... Ich glaube, die Zahlen...
Die Zahlen ganz gut.
Die Zahlen sind für Verkäufer ganz gut, aber das ist...
Oder?
Ich habe gehört, dass die gut zahlen, aber ich habe keine konkreten Zahlen gehört.
Ja, aber gut im Vergleich zu was?
Also, ich habe mal mit jemandem gesprochen, der im Apple Store in London, in der Region Street arbeitet. Und der hat einen recht gut dotierten...
Kannst du das sagen? Den kennt keiner. Was?
Na, der hat mir auch keine Zahlen genannt, weil er das, weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr, auf jeden Fall meinte er, das wäre ein gutes Auskommen. Also, man würde da schon auch ordentlich bezahlt werden für das, was man da macht. Das wäre definitiv keine Ausbeutung. Ob das jetzt auch so für die deutschen Stores gilt, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Also, dass die da überdurchschnittlich verdienen, ist schon klar.
Aber die machen definitiv keinen ausgebeuteten Eindruck da. Dafür sind die irgendwie echt freundlich. Wer weiß, wir nehmen gerne Tipps an über unsere tolle Kontaktadresse. Haben wir jetzt eigentlich eine tolle Kontaktadresse? Wir haben noch irgendwie...
Funktionieren die die ganzen E-Bi-Datei? Ich glaube, meine E-Mail-Adresse hat funktioniert, meine max.mobilemax.de.
Ja, aber wir haben auch, glaube ich, diese Team-Adresse eingerichtet. Team-Ad, mobilemax.de. Es gibt wahrscheinlich heute diesmal keine Kapitel, weil wir... Weil der Netz immer abgewandert ist. Und ich keine Zeit habe, mir das irgendwie nachrichtig durchzuhören und so. Wir müssen mal wirklich drüber nachdenken, ob wir hier Kapiteltasten machen. Ich weiß auch schon, wie. Alles wird ganz großartig werden.
Ewige Blumenkraft.
Also sagen wir jetzt schön artig Tschüss. Und vielen Dank für's Zuhören. Bis bald!
Ich mich mal wirklich!
Hast du das gehört?
Ja, super!